SIMPLY JUDICIARY COMMITTEE WE
DO NOT YET HAVE A QUORUM WE
HAVE A COUPLE AUTHORS TO WILL
START AS A SUB COMMITTEE
PENDING OTHER MEMBERS. WHO WILL
BE JOINING US SO WE'LL START
WITH ITEM NUMBER ONE AB TWENTY
FOUR SIXTY THREE. THIS WEEK'S
BILL SO FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO
ARE WATCHING AND OUT ON THE
PHONES WE ARE AGAIN HOLDING A
COMMITTEE HEARING TRYING TO BE
SOCIALLY DISTANT AND
APPROPRIATE THERE IS PLENTY OF
OPPORTUNITY TO WEIGH IN EITHER
TELEPHONICALLY OR IN OUR VIDEO
ROOM LOOKS LIKE SOMEBODY'S IN
THE VIDEO ROOM. AND THAT IS
GOOD. THERE IF YOU WANT TO CALL
IN AND JOIN. THERE IS A PHONE
NUMBER ON THE- BROADCAST THAT
YOU CAN CALL IN OR YOU CAN
CHECK OUT THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE
AND GET ALL THE INFORMATION
THERE. SO OPERATOR IF YOU WOULD
OPEN THE PHONE LINES FOR AB
TWENTY FOUR SIXTY THREE. WE
WILL. THEN THE AGAIN. AND AS
MENTIONED BEFORE BEING PROPERLY
ATTIRED IN THIS COMMITTEE IS
WEARING. THE MASS SKATE FACE
MAX GOOD FOR THE NEW SYSTEM MS
WICKS THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBER. AN URBAN INSTITUTE
REPORT FROM DECEMBER NINETEENTH
SORRY DECEMBER TWENTY NINETEEN
ESTIMATED 26% OF CALIFORNIANS
HAD A DEAD IN COLLECTION. SINCE
THE START OF THE COPA NINETEEN
PANDEMIC CALIFORNIA'S
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE JUMPED FROM
FIVE POINT 5% TO RECORD FIFTEEN
POINT 5% IN APRIL. WITH FOUR
POINT SIX MILLION CALIFORNIANS
WHO HAVE FILED FOR UNEMPLOYMENT
CLAIMS. THEREFORE WITH A COVER
NINETEEN CRISIS MANY
CALIFORNIANS WHO MAY ALREADY BE
IN DEBTS WILL FIND THEMSELVES
AND EVEN MORE HARDSHIP. WITH
THE INCREASE FINANCIAL STRUGGLE
SOME LOW INCOME CONSUMERS AND
HOMEOWNERS MAY ALSO FACE THE
THREAT OF LOSING THEIR HOMES.
THE EAST BAY COMMUNITY LAW
CENTER COMPLETED A REPORT THAT
INVESTIGATED A PROCESS THE
CREDITORS HAVE BEEN. SEEKING
FOR CLOSURES ON HOMES FOR
JUDGMENTS BASED ON UNSECURED
DEBT. THIS REPORT FROM THE EAST
BAY COMMUNITY LAW CENTER FOUND
THAT THESE CREDITORS HAVE BEEN
FOR CLOSING HOMES BASED ON
SMALL AMOUNTS OF DEBT. IN
PARTICULAR THIS PRACTICE HAS
BEEN AFFECTING LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. THE
PRACTICE OF COURSE FOR CLOSING
ON HOMES BASED ON SMALL AMOUNTS
OF UNSECURED DEBT IS
PROBLEMATIC GIVEN THE FINANCIAL
DIFFICULTIES EMERGING FROM THE
COPA NINETEEN PANDEMIC. AND
EXACERBATES EXISTING HOUSING
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. AB TWENTY FOUR
SIXTY THREE WILL ENSURE THAT
LOW INCOME HOMEOWNERS IN
CALIFORNIA WILL NOT LOSE THEIR
HOMES. AS THEY ARE STRUGGLING
TO PAY THEIR DEBTS ESPECIALLY
DURING THE COPA NINETEEN
CRISIS. THIS BILL WILL PREVENT
FORECLOSURES ON A PERSON'S
PRINCIPAL PLACE OF RESIDENCE
AND PREVENT THE FOR THE
ADDITIONAL INCREASE IN
HOMELESSNESS. STAKEHOLDERS TO
RAISE QUESTIONS REGARDING
DEFINITIONS IN THE BILL. AND
WE'VE HAD VERY PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATIONS WE WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THEM TO ALLEVIATE
ANY ADDITIONAL CONCERNS.
CALIFORNIA THERE ARE STRUGGLING
FINANCIALLY RIGHT NOW MORE THAN
EVER- NEED TO TAKE STEPS TO
PROVIDE PROTECTIONS TO THE MOST
VULERABLE BY ENSURING THAT
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS WERE
FACING FINANCIAL HARDSHIP. CAN
KEEP THEIR HOMES. THIS BILL HAS
BEEN- SUPPORTED BY A WIDE
VARIETY OF CONSUMER GROUPS. THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY THE CALIFORNIA REALTORS
ASSOCIATION AND AMONG OTHERS-
AND I WOULD RESPECT FASTER I
THOUGHT. THANK YOU THIS WORKS
WE HAVE. TWO WITNESSES TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT MIGUEL SOTO
AND DOCTOR PRASAD
KRISHNAMOORTHY AND MY THIS IS
BOTH THERE ON THE TELEPHONE BUT
LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE SOMEONE IN A
REMOTE. VIDEO ROOM. OKAY SO DO
WE HAVE MISTER SOTO OR- DR
KRISHNAMOORTHY ON THE PHONE.
YEAH OKAY PLEASE PROCEED. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS SET UP AND A
STAFF ATTORNEY IN CLINICAL
INSTRUCTOR AT THE FIFTY
LAWCENTER WHICH IS A MEMBER OF
THE CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME TO A
COALITION OUR CLINIC DIRECTOR
UNDER THE CONSUMERS EACH YEAR
WITH THAT COLLECTION MATTERS I
THINK WITH MANY HOMEOWNERS ARE
LOW INCOME AND MOSTLY SENIORS
IMMIGRANTS AND PEOPLE OF COLOR
WHO IS GOOD FOR SMALL AND TO
GET THAT. POP UP IN CREDIT CARD
WITHOUT THIS AROUND FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS MANY OF THE
SOMEONE OR SUCH TROUBLE PER
MONTH ANYTHING YEAR TO PAY BACK
THAT WITH MORE THAN ONE CALL
KEEPING THE OPEN MEDICAL CARE
TO REPAY A LOAN BECAUSE OF HIGH
INTEREST RATE THE IMPACT ON
FEET. NEVER CATCH UP AND IT.
TOO WHEN IT. THE WAY TO. OTHER
BIG HELP MAKE LEVY BUT EVERY
QUITE OPEN ACOSTA QUESTIONS CAN
I USE MY HOME I CAN'T BY THE
MONEY TO PAY THIS THAT. RIGHT
NOW WE HAVE TO KILL THE PEOPLE
THAT YES THE FAMILY MIGHT LOSE
THE WHOLE OVER THE HUNDRED
UTILITY BILL. FOR THE ONE
THOUSAND DOLLAR CARD TO. A
COMPUTER BECAUSE IT UNNECESSARY.
BELIEVE THE HARMFUL TO SEE BY
HOME. LIKE PICKING UP AT THE-
LONG NEVER. RETIRED SCHOOL
TEACHERS CAN'T PATIENT.
UNDOCUMENTED FAST FOOD WORKERS
AND OTHER VOLATILE HOMEOWNERS
WHO HAD LEARNED ABOUT THE RIGHT
NOW. CALIFORNIA AFFECTED LET
ANY UNDERTAKEN TO MAKE THAT ACT
LIKE A MORTGAGE. AB TWENTY FOUR
SIXTY PREFIX OF THIS AND
JUSTICE. A QUESTION MARK THE
WILL EXPLAIN HOW BILLS PAID
LENDERS AND LEAVE THEM OTHER
WAYS. A COLLECTED THAT. I'M
HERE TO EXPECT UNNECESSARY THIS
BILL IS TO MAKE SURE WE PROTECT
OUR HOMEOWNERS WHO LIVE IN THE
HOME BECAUSE THE MEDICAL
BUILDING AT THE FORT. FOR A
LONG PRO CARD DOES NOT AB
POSSESSING AUCTIONED OFF. I'M
HERE TO SHARE THE HOPE OF EVERY
PEOPLE LIKE THAT NUMBER THE
NEXT TIME IF PEOPLE CAN MOTHER
ACT BUT IF YOU CAN BE EVICTED
ELLEN PAGE THE CARD THAT. YOU
CAN FIND A LOOK IN THE EYE AND
SAY NO. YOUR HOME IS SAFE. WE
ARE DRIVE HOME. THANK YOU. DOC
CHRISTIAN MURPHY. I THANK YOU
MY NAME IS WITHOUT QUESTION
WITH THE AND I AM A PROFESSOR
OF LAW AT UC BERKELEY SCHOOL OF
LAW WHERE I TEACH AND CONDUCT
RESEARCH IN THE AREAS OF
FINANCIAL REGULATION AND
CONTRACT LBGT FROM THE A LAW
SCHOOL TO PHD IN ECONOMICS FROM
THE UC BERKELEY DEPARTMENT OF
ECONOMICS IN MY RESEARCH HAS
BEEN PUBLISHED. IN LEADING
JOURNALS AND LAW AND ECONOMICS
I BELIEVE THAT AB TWO FOUR SIX
THREE WILL MAKE CONSUMERS
BETTER OFF- FIRST AND FOREMOST
THAT MIGUEL EXPLAINED IT WILL
HELP JUDGMENT DEBTORS TO KEEP
THEIR HOMES IN THIS IS AN
ESPECIALLY TIED THE CONCERN- AT
CALIFORNIA'S CAME INTO THIS
CRISIS WITH THE HIGHEST PER
CAPITA DEBT TOTALS IN THE
COUNTRY AND CURRENTLY HOUSEHOLD
BORROW TO REPLACE LOST INCOME.
IN THE MIDST OF COLD AT NINETY.
SECONDLY AB TWO FOUR TWO FOUR
SIX THREE UNLIKELY TO HAVE ANY
APPRECIABLE EFFECT. ON CREDIT
MARKETS OVERALL AND THIS IS
BECAUSE THE OVERALL NUMBER OF
FOR SALE OUTSIDE OF.
TRADITIONAL FOR COOK
FORECLOSURE AND BANKRUPTCY IS
VERY SMALL IF YOU LOOK AT THE
EAST PLEASE TAKE MANY DOCTORS
REPORT. IT'S ON THE ORDER OF
SEVERAL HUNDRED A YEAR. WHEREAS
THERE ARE ABOUT SIXTY THOUSAND
FORECLOSURES AND ABOUT SIXTY
THOUSAND BANKRUPTCY FILING IN
CALIFORNIA THE LITTLE IN IN IN
IN A GIVEN YEAR. SO THIS IS A
VERY SMALL LITTLE UP LOOK AT
THE PARK FROM THE STANDPOINT OF
THE OVERALL CALIFORNIA ECONOMY
AND OF COURSE IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT TO THE PEOPLE WHO WHO
UNDERGO. ALSO KEEP IN MIND THAT
THE RIGHT OF MORTGAGE AND ALL
THOSE OTHER SECURED LENDERS.
ARE COMPLETELY UNAFFECTED ARE
MOSTLY UNAFFECTED. AS WE ARE
THE RIGHT THE UNSECURED LENDERS
IN THE TRADITIONAL FORECLOSURE
OR IN A BANKRUPTCY SO ALL
PROJECTS THAT THE KIND OF. ACT
AND YOUR BEFORE WITH A BIT OF
THE FOR THE ACTION EFFECTS ON
CREDIT MARKETS ARE LIKELY TO BE
SMALL. FINALLY A TWO FORTY
THREE PRESERVES THE RIGHT TO
SEEK A COURT ORDERED SALE FOR
OTHER CREDITORS BUT DID
<c.cyan>UARDIANS. SEEKING FELT THE</c>
PORT AND AFTER THE VICTIM SO
THEIR RIGHTS ARE UNAFFECTED.
THE GOOD AT WHAT WE TYPICALLY
DO NOT RESEARCH THAT ABOUT WHAT
AB TWO FOUR SIX THREE LIKELY
EFFECTS WILL BE- WE- GENERALLY
LOOK TO- PAPERS THAT STUDY
EFFECTIVE INCREASES IN THE
HOMESTEAD EXEMPTION. IN THE
QUEUE AND ACT LOOKS PLAYED WHAT
THE GOOD AT THE ELEGY. IF WE
TAKE THAT HOMESTEAD EXEMPTION
RESEARCH AB TWO FOUR SIX THREE
IS LIKELY TO ACTUALLY INCREASE
THE TOTAL AMOUNT OF ON SECURE
CREDIT. THAT THE TEAM BY
CONSUMERS. AND INCREASE WILL BE
LARGEST FOR LOW INCOME
HOMEOWNERS. AND THE REASON WHY
IS THAT AB TWO TO FOUR SIXTY
WILL ACTUALLY INCREASE CREDIT
DEMAND AMONG BORROWERS. WHO
VALUE THE INSURANCE THAT IT
PROVIDES. AND THE EXISTING
EMPIRICAL RESEARCH SUGGESTS
THAT THIS DEMAND AFFECT
OUTWEIGH ANY SUPPLY BACKED. UP
TO THE- BY LENDERS. AB FOUR SIX
THREE I'D LIKE LOW FLUX. IN
CONSUMER EXPAND THE OF TIME IN
THINK ABOUT THE SIMPLY IN THE
EVENT OF A FORCED HOMES HELP
THAT WOULD NORMALLY HAPPEN
UNDER EXISTING LAW THAT DIDN'T
HAPPEN CONSUMERS WILL BE ABLE
TO STAND. UP SPEND MORE ON THE
SHELVES. THIRDLY AB TWO FOUR
SIX WITH UNLIKELY THE FACT
DELINQUENCY THAT ALL IN
UNSECURED MARKETS. IT MAY HAVE
A SMALL INCREASE IN INTEREST
RATES FOR SOME SAID OF
BORROWERS. AND FINALLY AB TWO
FOUR SIX THREE UNLIKELY TO HAVE
ANY EFFECT AT ALL ON TO CHURCH
MARKETS IS IN NO AFFECT ON
INTEREST RATES NO AFFECT ON
CLEVELAND SEIZE. UPPER HOUSING
AUTOMOBILES AND OTHER CONSUMER
DURABLES. UP FINALLY AS I
MENTIONED BEFORE JUST BECAUSE
THE NUMBER OF PORTS HOME SALES
OUTSIDE A FORECLOSURE A
BANKRUPTCY A SMALL ALL OF THE
FACT. THAT THEY DO EXIST. ARE
LIKELY TO BE VERY SMALL. THESE
REASONS I BELIEVE. WE BETTER
OFF AS A RESULT OF AB TO FORCE
THREE. AND I. BECAUSE THAT YOU
GO A THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
BEFORE WE GO TO OTHER WITNESSES
I'D LIKE TO STYLE SAPPORO. CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE. STONE HERE
STONE HERE GALLAGHER. CHAO CHOW
HERE TO. GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ
PRESENT HOLDEN. KALRA KALRA
HERE KILEY. MAIENSCHEIN
OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE HERE YES.
REYES PRESENT. THANK YOU WE DO
HAVE A QUORUM. IS THERE ANYONE
IN THE HEARING ROOM WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. ALL RIGHT SEE NINE
OPERATOR. THEY'RE OPEN UP THE
LINES FOR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO. GIVE US
THEIR NAME THEIR AFFILIATION IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FOUR SIXTY
THREE. KILL IF YOU'RE INTO PART
PLEASE PRESS ONE DIDN'T GIRL AT
THE TIME WE'LL GO TO LINE
TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS CAN
YELL CANDOR CARTER ON BEHALF OF
THE NATIONAL CONSUMER LAW
CLINIC IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. BILL GO TO LINE TWENTY
PLEASE I HAD. GOOD MORNING
CHAIRMAN FOUND IN MEMBERS THIS
IS LEE FERRAN THE DIRECTOR OF
LITIGATION PRABANDHA WITH THE
PUBLIC LAWCENTER IN ORANGE
COUNTY AND WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FOUR FIFTY
THREE. THANK YOU. LINE NINETEEN.
THAT ARE LIKE ONCE IN A JACKET
AND A RESCUE CENTER THE
PARTICIPATION OF CAMPUS WITHOUT
WE ARE INSTRUCTED OF AB. TWENTY
FOUR SIXTY THREE. THANK YOU.
THANK TWENTY ONE. JANUARY
TERRACE ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT. NINE
THIRTY TWO. GOOD MORNING ANNA
BACK ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF BILL
CLINTON OR. LINE THIRTY ONE.
FOR NINE THIRTY WHEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. BUT NOT THE LINE
TWENTY FIVE YOUR MIND IS OPEN.
WELL ACTUALLY PART CAN ONLY
THAT DEREK LEGAL SERVICES. AND
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORTER OF
THE. EIGHTY TWENTY FOUR SIXTY
THREE. IF THERE ARE ANY OTHER
THAN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
TO ZERO AT THIS TIME. I KNOW
OTHERS IN SUPPORT GREAT THANK
YOU I DON'T HAVE ANY LISTED
OPPOSITION BUT IS THERE ANYONE
ON THE LINE. OR OTHERWISE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. OPERATOR YOU HAVE
ANYONE IN THE QUEUE FOR
OPPOSITION. YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION THE FIRST ONE DIDN'T
ZERO AT THIS TIME WE DO HAVE
PEOPLE QUEUING UP ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. THANK THIRTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
ROBERT WILSON WITH A CALIFORNIA
CREDIT UNION LEAGUE WE'RE NOT
OFFICIAL POSITION ON THE BILL-
BUT APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT
THE AUTHORED THE SPONSORS HAVE
BEEN DOING TO LEVY A
TELEMARKETER EARNS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AND TWENTY SEVEN.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MELANIE QUICK THAT THE
CALIFORNIA THINKERS AT THE
BEACH AND- ECHO THE COMMENTS
BEFORE ME GREAT PUBLIC DIALOGUE
THAT WE'VE HAD WITH THE AUTHOR
AND FUN THIRD THIS IS AN
INCREDIBLY RARELY USED TOOL
HOWEVER WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING OUR DIALOGUE AND
PERHAPS THE PUBLISHING FAMILY
SOME REASONABLE PARAMETERS
AROUND ABOUT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. AND THERE ARE NO OTHERS
ENOUGH OF THAT. GREAT THANK YOU
I WILL THEN BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE. AUSTIN'S THROUGH
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. RIGHT SEEING
NONE THIS WITH YOU MAY CLOSE
RESPECT FAST FOR AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU LOOKING FOR A MOTION
THE MOTION IS TO PASS. THANK
YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND KALRA PLEASE. STONE HI
STERN AYE GALLAGHER. JO JO I TO
CONSOLES HI GONZALEZ I HOLDEN
KALRA KALRA AYE KILEY.
MAIENSCHEIN OBERNOLTE. REYES HI.
REZAI. KILEY. THAT HAS FIVE A
FIVE ALREADY NEEDS ONE MORE
SOMEONE PUT THIS FEDERAL CALL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
THAT BRINGS US TO ITEM NUMBER
TWO AB TWENTY THREE THIRTY
EIGHT MS WEBER. OPERATOR WOULD
YOU OPEN THE LINES FOR AB
TWENTY THREE THIRTY EIGHT. MY
JOB IN. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS- I'M
HERE TO PRESENT TO YOU AB
TWENTY THREE THIRTY EIGHT AND
I'M ALWAYS EXCITED WHEN I GET A
CHANCE TO PRESENT A BILL BACKED
UP COMES OUT OF MY NEIGHBORHOOD
OUT OF THE COMMUNITY THIS WAS A
PART OF A THERE OUGHT TO BE A
LAW ACTIVITY WE DO EVERY YEAR
WE GET RECOMMENDATIONS AND IT'S
GOOD TO SEE EVERY NOW AND THEN
A RECOMMENDATION COMING FROM
THE CONSTITUENTS. THAT MOVES
ALL THE WAY THROUGH THE PROCESS
OF ACTUALLY GET STATE-
ORGANIZATIONAL SUPPORTS SO THIS
AB TWENTY THREE THIRTY EIGHT
COME FROM A AN ATTORNEY IN MY
DISTRICT WHO DEALS WITH THIS
ISSUE THIS BILL WOULD ADDRESS
THE MISALIGNMENT AND
CALIFORNIA'S PENAL AND CIVIL
CODES AND IT'S AS IT RELATES TO
FAMILY COURT THIS BILL WILL
PROVIDE A PROBATION AND ALL AND
AN ADDITIONAL AND ALTERNATIVE
SENTENCING OPTION. WHEN AN
INDIVIDUAL IS FOUND IN CONTEMPT
OF THE FAMILY LAW COURT ORDER
JUDGMENT UNDER CURRENT LAW
FAMILY COURT JUDGES ARE ONLY
ALLOWED TO IMPOSE COMMUNITY
SERVICE AND OR IMPRISONMENT FOR
NOT MORE THAN FIVE DAYS
ALTHOUGH CONTENT MAY BE USEFUL
TOOL FOR GAINING COMPLIANCE
WITH A COURT ORDER ACTUAL
CHRISTMAS OR COMMUNITY SERVICE
IS NOT ASSIST IN GETTING A
SUPPORT ORDER PAID. INDIVIDUALS
CHARGE MULTIPLE OF CONTEMPT FOR
FAILURE TO PAY CHILD SUPPORT AS
UP OVER TIME THIS THIS THANKS
OF PRIMARILY. THOSE WHO HAVE
OUR LIVE FROM PAYCHECK.
APPROVED BY IN THE- MASON ALOW
THEM TO WORK IN COME UP WITH
THE MONEY THEY OWE. THIS WAS
THIS SOME EXT THE APPS
AVAILABLE TO A JUDGE PURSUANT
TO A CAP OF FAMILY COAT COAT
PROBATION CAN OFTEN IS A BETTER
ALTERNATIVE THAN IMPRISONMENT
IN THESE CIRCUMSTANCES
FURTHERMORE GRANTING PROBATION
ON A CONDITIONAL SENTENCE WOULD
IN MANY CASES HAVE THE
ADVANTAGE OF INCREASING THE
ODDS FOR OBTAINING COMPLIANCE
WITH HIM WITH THE IMPOSITION OF
PROBATION OR A CONDITIONAL
SENTENCE THE PARTY WHO IS
SUBJECT TO THE COLD ORDER HAS
AN OPPORTUNITY TO GET BACK ON
TRACK AND- I WITH A COURT ORDER.
BILL IS SPONSORED THE LAWSUIT.
ALL OF THE ALSO GIVES ME THE
LAW OFFICE OF DON DEAL OF CLASS
WHO'S THE INDIVIDUAL IN MY
DISTRICT WHO WHO PROVIDED THIS
WHO MAVIS IDEAS AND
SUGGESTIONS- BUT SEVERAL OF THE
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE LIVED THEIR
SUPPORT TO THE CALIFORNIA.
ATTORNEYS FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
THE CALIFORNIA LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION THEIR FAMILY LAW
SECTION LOS ANGELES COUNTY BAR
SECTION AND THE WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY. HERE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS SOME
OF THIS BILL FOR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE IS DON DELECOUR
HERSELF- FROM DEAL OF QUIET LAW
FIRM- THIS BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION AND- AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AUTO.
THANK YOU I HAVE ONE LISTED
WITH THIS AND THAT IS DONE THE
LACK WERE. ON THE TELEPHONE. GO
AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS DON BELL AQUA I AM A
PRIVATE ATTORNEY IN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY A CERTIFIED FAMILY LAW
SPECIALIST FORMER PRESIDENT OF
THE SAN DIEGO FAMILY LAW PART
THOUGH SHE XIN. AND A COURT
APPOINTED ATTORNEY FOR THE
OFFICE OF ASSIGNED COUNSEL BOTH
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE WRITTEN
LETTERS OF STRONG SUPPORT FOR
AT. TWENTY THREE THIRTY EIGHT.
ONE MAN THE CODE OF CIVIL
PROCEDURE SECTION TWELVE
EIGHTEEN AND AUTHORIZED
PROBATION AS A SENTENCING
OPTION IN FAMILY COURT CONTEMPT
CASES. AB TWENTY THREE THIRTY
EIGHT OFFERED THE SAME
SENTENCING OPTION OF PROBATION
ADNAN MISDEMEANOR AND CRIMINAL
CONTEMPT CASES UNDER THE PENAL
CODE. IT WILL REDUCE COSTS FOR
COURT STAFFING COUNSEL FEES AND
COSTS OF INCARCERATION BY
ALLOWING FOR PLEA AGREEMENTS TO
OCCUR IN LIEU OF TRIAL THIS IS
GOOD FOR BOTH THE PROSECUTION
AND THE DEFENSE. A GIVE JUDGES
THE DISCRETION TO LOOK AT THE
REASONING WHY FOR EXAMPLE
APPARENTLY UNABLE TO PAY
SUPPORT PERHAPS BECAUSE OF THE
LOSS OF A JOB. IT OFFERS THE
GUILTY PARTY THE ABILITY TO
CONFORM TO THE CORRECT BEHAVIOR
SUCH AS CONDITIONING PROBATION
ON COMPLIANCE WITH A COURT
ORDER TO PAY SUPPORT. THAT'S A
WIN WIN FOR BOTH SIDES THE
PARTY PAINT SUPPORT WILL NOT
LOSE THEIR JOBS MAY ACTUALLY
GAIN EMPLOYMENT. WELL THE
SUPPORTED PARTY RECEIVED A MUCH
NEEDED SUPPORT TO TAKE CARE OF
CHILDREN. FINALLY THIS BILL
ALSO CLARIFIED A SORT OF
AMBIGUITY IN THE CURRENT
STATUTE BETWEEN SUBSECTION A
AND THAT SECTION THREE.
SUBSECTION SEAT IS WHAT APPLIES
TO ALL CASES BROUGHT INTO THE
FAMILY CODE SECTION SECTION HEY
APPLY TO ALL OTHER CIVIL CASES.
BUT THAT IS NOT CLEAR BECAUSE
THERE IS NO LANGUAGE CURRENTLY
IN THE STATUTE WHICH STATES
THAT AND SO THERE IS A
CORRECTION IN AB TWENTY THREE
THIRTY EIGHT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THIS IS CLEAR. I WANT TO THANK
DOCTOR WEBER FOR ENERGY SEEN
THIS BILL AND THE COMMITTEE FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION WE URGE AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL. ALL RIGHT SEE
NONE OPERATOR IS THERE ANYONE
ON THE LINE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
THREE THIRTY EIGHT. Q. IF
YOU'RE INTO PART PLEASE PRESS
THE ONE BEEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WE WILL GO TO LINE. THIRTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MISTER
CHAIR THIS IS CAPITA BARTOLO
WITH THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY AND WE ARE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE THIRTY
EIGHT. NINE THIRTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THE CHECK YOUR
MUTE BUTTON. MOVING ON TO LINE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. CAN YOU COULD HEAR IT
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEYS FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
IN SUPPORT. THERE ANY FURTHER
IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THE TIME. THERE
ARE NO OTHERS AT THE PORT.
THANK YOU I'M GOING TO MOVE TO
OPPOSITION I DON'T HAVE ANY
OPPOSITION LISTED IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE- HEARING ROOM
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. ALRIGHT SEE NONE
OPERATOR IS THERE ANYONE ON THE
LINE FOR OPPOSITION. PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION WE HAVE A LINE
THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THIS IS STACEY TADD FROM
UC IRVINE CONSUMER LAW CLINIC
AND I WAS ACTUALLY CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FOUR SIXTY
THREE BUT WITH KICKED INTO THE
OPPOSITION MINE BUT I'M CALLING
IN SUPPORT. OKAY WE'RE ON AB
TWENTY THREE THIRTY EIGHT.
THERE IF ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE BEEN ZERO AT
THE TIME. AND NO ONE IS IN
OPPOSITION RIGHT THANK YOU
OPERATOR OF BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS FROM KANAME. THANK YOU
WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND THAT MOTION IS. TO PASS.
SEE NO OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS THIS WILL REMAIN CLOSE
IT'S ALL ON BEHALF OF THE
ATTORNEY DEL LOCK LOCK AND
MYSELF I RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN
I BILLS. THANK YOU. CALL THE
ROLL PLEASE STONE BY STONE AYE
GALLAGHER. JO JO I TWO GUNS ALL
IS GONZALEZ I HOLDEN KALRA
RIGHT KALRA AYE KILEY KILEY AYE
MAIENSCHEIN. OBERNOLTE
OBERNOLTE I REYES HI RES I. IT
HAS SEVEN VOTE THAT BILL IS OUT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. RIGHT WE
WILL NOW- LET'S SEE MR CHOW ARE
YOU READY ON AB TWENTY FOUR
FORTY TWO SO WE OPERATOR OF THE
LINES FOR AB TWENTY FOUR FORTY
TWO PLEASE. GIVE THE LINE TO
HELP WITH. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AB TWENTY FOUR FORTY
TWO WOULD REQUIRE THAT SOCIAL
MEDIA PLATFORMS THIS CLOSE
WHETHER OR NOT THEY HAVE A
POLICY TO ADDRESS THE SPREAD OF
MISINFORMATION. CURRENTLY
DEFINED TO INCLUDE INFORMATION
WHICH IS INTENTIONALLY
MISLEADING INACCURATE
COORDINATED AND DECEPTIVE
PROMOTION OR SUPPRESSION OF
INFORMATION AND PRACTICES
INTENDED TO MANIPULATE THE- OF
USERS. SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS
THAT VIOLATE THIS LAW WOULD
HAVE THIRTY DAYS TO REMEDY
THEIR VIOLATION. ACCORDING TO
THE PEW RESEARCH CENTER IN
201955% OF US ADULTS GOT THEIR
NEWS FROM SOCIAL MEDIA. IN YET
ANOTHER REPORT THEY FOUND THAT
DESPITE CONTROVERSY SURROUNDING
FAKE NEWS 73% OF US ADULTS
CONTINUE TO RELY ON GETTING
NEWS FROM SOCIAL MEDIA SITES.
WHAT IS MORE STE WHAT IS MORE
TROUBLING IS THAT APPROXIMATELY
50% OF THE PEOPLE SHARE A NEW
STORY FOUND OUT LATER THAT THE
NEWS STORY WAS FALSE. AS THE
CLOVER NINETEEN CRISIS
CONTINUES TO UNFOLD MANY
INDIVIDUALS HAVE ALREADY BEEN
HIT WITH IN- MISINFORMATION
ABOUT HOW THE VIRUS IS SPREAD.
ALL OFFERING TO SELL MEDICAL
SUPPLIES TO FIGHT AGAINST THE
VIRUS. MORE MORE PEOPLE ENGAGED
IN SOCIAL MEDIA CAN SPREAD MORE
MISINFORMATION BELIEVING IT TO
BE TROUBLED. CREATING A VICIOUS
CYCLE. ACCORDING TO ANALYSTS
EARLY IN THE YEARINFORMATION
ABOUT CLOVER NINETEEN WAS
SCARCE LEADING TO A DATE AVOID
UNFORTUNATELY DEVOID WAS
QUICKLY FILL WOULD PROBLEMATIC
CONTENT. BY BAD ACTORS EAGER TO
EXPLOIT THE SITUATION. BY
REQUIRING SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS TO DISCLOSE WHAT THEY
WHAT ARE THEY HOW SUCH A POLICY
THE USERS AND THE PUBLIC WOULD
HAVE THE ABILITY TO ASSESS THE
INFORMATION THEY ARE CONSUMING.
CURRENTLY MANY PLATFORM TO NOT
HAVE SUCH A POLICY DEALING WITH
MISINFORMATION. SINCE SOCIAL
MEDIA PLATFORMS FORM AN
INTEGRAL PART OF WHOLE ADULT
CONSUME NEWS IT IS IMPORTANT TO
KNOW WHICH OF THESE PLATFORMS
ARE. TAKING STEPS TO ADDRESS
THE SPREAD OF MISINFORMATION.
EIGHTY FOUR TWENTY FOUR FORTY
TWO DOES THAT. I HAVE PROFESSOR
EMERITUS JOHN SIMS FROM THE
GEORGE SCHOOL OF LAW AND EXPERT
ON CONSTITUTIONAL LAW HERE TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY. AND ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YES NO POSITION
ON A BILL THAT CAN SPEAK
SPECIFICALLY TO THE
CONSTITUTIONAL ISSUES RAISED BY
THE OPPOSITION. RIGHT THANK YOU
WE WILL MOVE THEN TO PROFESSOR
SINCE WHO IS WITH US AND OUR
WITNESS VIDEO CONFERENCE ROOM.
GOOD MORNING- THE FIRST
AMENDMENT PROVIDE STRONG
PROTECTION FOR THOSE WHO WISH
TO EXPRESS THEMSELVES. AND TO A
DEGREE IT ALSO. PROVIDES
PROTECTION. TO THOSE WHEN THE
GOVERNMENT'S TRYING TO COMPEL
SPEECH- AB TWENTY FOUR FORTY
TWO S. DESCRIBED WOULD REQUIRE
EACH SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORM TO
DISCLOSE WHETHER IT HAS A
POLICY TO DEAL WITH. SYSTEMATIC
SPREAD OF MISINFORMATION. I IN
MY VIEW NO SUBSTANTIAL
CONSTITUTIONAL QUESTION CAN BE
RAISED ABOUT THIS ASPECT OF AB
TWENTY FOUR FORTY TWO. ARE
THERE ARE MANY DISCLOSURE
REQUIREMENTS AFTER A COUPLE TO
THOSE PROVIDING GOODS AND
SERVICES IN FIRST AMENDMENT LAW
ACCEPTS IT DID THIS EVERY DAY
PROCESS OF REGULATION WHICH
PROTECTS AGAINST FLOP FRAUD
EXPLOITATION AND OTHER INJURIES.
FOR EXAMPLE I IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY FIVE THE SUPREME COURT
DECIDED A CASE CALLED SOUTER.
OF WHICH CONCLUDED THAT AN
ATTORNEY COULD BE REQUIRED TO
MAKE CERTAIN DISCLOSURES
RELATED TO HIS PROVISION OF
SERVICES TO CLIENTS AND HE HAD
TO MAKE THOSE DISCLOSURES TO
PROSPECTIVE. CLIENTS SIMILARLY
IN CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS ARE
REQUIRED IN AND IN NUMEROUS
WAYS TO MAKE AFFIRMATIVE
DISCLOSURES SO FOR EXAMPLE
UNDER RULE ONE POINT FOUR POINT
TWO CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS ARE
REQUIRED TO DISCLOSE TO
PROSPECTIVE CLIENTS IN ALMOST
ALL CIRCUMSTANCES WHETHER OR
NOT THEY HAVE. MALPRACTICE
INSURANCE. HI EVERYONE A
CALIFORNIA'S FAMILIAR- WITH THE
UBIQUITOUS STUFF PROP SIXTY
FIVE WARNING SOME OF WHICH ARE
REQUIRED. OF THOSE- SELLING
SERVICES- AND GOODS WHEN THAT
WOULD RESULT IN THE EXPOSURE-
CONSUMERS TO DANGEROUS
CHEMICALS. SO THE FIRST
AMENDMENT DOES NOT PREVENT
CONSUMER PROTECTION DISCARDED
PROTECTION DISCLOSURES OF THESE
TYPES. AND I'M CONFIDENT THAT
IF ANY FIRST AMENDMENT.
ARGUMENT WERE RAISED- ALONG THE
LINES OF THE COMPELLED SPEECH
DR AGAINST AB TWENTY FOUR FOUR
TWO THAT THAT CLAIM WOULD BE
REJECTED THANKS VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU HAD MR TELL THE-
ANALYSIS LISTS A NUMBER OF
AMENDMENTS. HI THAT'S CORRECT
UP. ARE THERE IS A SET OF
AMENDMENTS ACT OUT I AM
ACCEPTING A GRANDMA HERE AND-
YEAH I'VE ALSO BEEN TALKING
WITH THE ALL THE OPPOSITION AND
STAKEHOLDERS ON FURTHER
AMENDING THE LANGUAGE AND YOU
KNOW TO TAKE A LOOK. THE
DEFINITION OF SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORM AS WELL AS THE
DEFINITION OF MISINFORMATION SO
THOSE AMENDMENTS WILL GO AND
LATER. ON BUT THE MEMBERS ARE
SUGGESTED IN THE ANALYSIS ARE
YOU ALWAYS WILL BE ACCEPTED
TODAY OKAY CORRECT. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL. ALL RIGHT CA
NINETY MIGHT BE EDITION ALL
CALLERS YEAH TO SUPPORT. YEAH I
WOULD ANYONE ON THE LINES. LIKE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY FOUR FORTY TWO. IF
YOU'RE INTO PART WITH FEDERAL
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME LINE
FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AGAIN NINE FORTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MOVING ON TO LINE
THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
LINE THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. OKAY AT THE
TIME IF YOU ARE IN. THE FACT
ONE ZERO IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK. THERE ARE NO OTHER
SECURE. OKAY THANKYOU IS THERE
OPPOSITION I HAVE ONE LISTED
OPPOSITION SAMANTHA CORBIN FROM
ELECTRONIC FRONTIER FOUNDATION.
I'M ON THE LINE IF YOU CAN HEAR
ME YES WE CAN HEAR PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. I'VE MET THE CORPORATE
ON BEHALF OF THE ELECTRONIC
FRONTIER FOUNDATION.
RESPECTFULLY AND OPPOSITION AB.
TWO FOUR FOUR TWO WE ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT CUTS ON
CONSTITUTIONALITY ISSUES- WITH
THE LANGUAGE IN PARTICULAR-
THAT THE DEFINITION OUR
OBJECTIVE AND OVERLY BROAD. AND
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
AUTHORED OFFICE AND WILL
CONTINUE TO DO SO AND
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS TO
CONSIDER. ME THANK YOU. THANK
YOU IS THERE ANYONE IN THE
HEARING ROOM WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB
TWENTY FOUR FORTY TWO. SEEING
NONE IS THERE ANYONE ON THE
PHONE NINE TWO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB
TWENTY FOUR FORTY TWO. IF
YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND WE DO HAVE PEOPLE
QUEUING UP IT'LL BE A MOMENT.
THANK YOU. I WOULD PROVIDE THE
LIGHT NUMBERS.
MY NUMBER TWENTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU THIS IS ROBERT CAL AND WITH
THE INTERNET ASSOCIATION- WE
OPPOSE THE BILL. EIGHT NO THE
AUTHOR'S EFFORTS TO WORK WITH
US MOVING FORWARD- BUT IT PRINT
WE DO BELIEVE AB TWENTY FOUR
FORTY TWO IS UNNECESSARY- THE
MOST WIDELY USED SOCIAL MEDIA.
PLATFORMS A COMPANIES ALREADY
HAVE STRICT RULES AND POLICIES
ABOUT WHAT IS AND IS NOT
ALLOWED ON THEIR PLATFORMS IN
THESE ROLES ALREADY DRESSED
WAYS PLATFORMS APPROACH-
BERRIES FORMS OF MISINFORMATION
AND MANIPULATION OF THE SITE-
THAT AS FAR AS- BEING PUBLICLY
AVAILABLE THEY ARE. NOT
DISCUSSED AT LENGTH ON PAGES
DEVOTED TO THESE RULES AND
POLICIES AND ARE AVAILABLE TO
BE VIEWED AT ANY TIME BY USERS-
PERSPECTIVE USERS FOR THE
GENERAL PUBLIC- SO- WE ARE
BECAUSE OF THE BILL- AS WE
BELIEVE IT'S NOT NECESSARY BUT
IT SHOULD. OF THE AUTHOR THANK
YOU. THANK YOU IS THERE ANYONE
ELSE IN OFFICE. AND WE'RE NOT
GOING TO TAKE ANY FURTHER
TESTIMONY IF YOU COULD JUST
GIVE US YOUR NAME AND YOUR
AFFILIATION PLEASE. LINE FORTY
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
CAMERA DIMITRI WITH TECHNOLOGY
WE ARE ALSO RESPECTFULLY
BECAUSE THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
THERE ARE NO OTHER CHEN Q.
THANK YOU OPERATOR I'M GOING TO
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
THAT. THIS HIGHLY. I'M MISTER
SHOW USED MENTIONED THAT
THERE'S GOING TO BE A-
AMENDMENT THE CHANGES THE
DEFINITION OF MISINFORMATION
WHAT IS ONE OF THEM TELL. ART
WELL THE DETAILS ARE STILL
BEING WORKED ON- BUT I'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH YEAH- YEAH I
INTERNET ASSOCIATION AND SO THE
OPPOSITION DFL FIVE TO
BASICALLY TRY TO REFINE THE
DEFINITION. OF WE HAVEN'T
DECIDED ON ONE PARTICULAR
DEFINITION AS YET BUT THERE'S
BEEN SEVERAL ITERATIONS OF THAT
THE VERY THE- DEFINITION BEING
CIRCULATED RIGHT NOW ALSO-
CERTAIN PARTIES ARE. Y'ALL THEM
THEY LIKE ONE VERSION NOT MORE
THAN THE OTHERS SO WE JUST NEED
AND SORTED OUT ALL OUT- BUT IT
DEALT PRIMARILY IT DEALS WITH
THE- THE FIRST THREE ITEMS OF
THE DEFINITION. AND SO.
SECIFIC EIGHT REGARDING THE
WAY. OF AROUND INTENTIONALLY
MISLEADING COORDINATING
DECEPTIVE AND ALSO THE- THE
BEHAVIOR PIECE ALSO SO I THINK-
SO YOU KNOW THERE IS NO
DEFINITIVE- OF VERSION AS YET
THAT SO AGREED. AGREED TO BY
EVERYBODY AT THIS POINT I SEE
AND- I YEAH I GUESS QUESTION
FOR EITHER FOR YOU OR FOR THE
FOR YOUR WITNESS ON. THIS
FIRST- PRONG ASKED
INTENTIONALLY MISLEADING OR
INACCURATE SO THERE'S AN INTENT
REQUIREMENT WHICH- WAS AN
IMPORTANT SAFEGUARD IN OTHER
AREAS WERE PLAYING WITH- MAKING
A JUDGMENT ABOUT. FALSENESS
LIKE DEFAMATION THAT YOU KNOW
YOU HAVE TO HAVE THAT. THIS
INTENT REQUIREMENT IT'S
IMPORTANT SAFEGUARD AGAINST A
CHILLING EFFECT BUT I.
WONDERING HOW THAT WORKS IN
THIS CONTEXT I MEAN. BECAUSE
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TOHAVE A
SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORM MAKING A
DETERMINATION IN REAL TIME-
ABOUT WHAT WAS KNOWN WHAT THE
INTENT OF THE CONTENT SHARE
WISE- AND THEN YOU KNOW- DOES
THE SAME STANDARD HAVE TO BE
MET FOR EACH PERSON WHO SHARES
THE CONTENT AFTER THAT- OR WHAT
HAPPENS IF THEY TAKE A PIECE OF
ORIGINAL CONTENT THAT MAY BE
WHAT IS. I SHARED WITH WITH ILL
INTENT- BUT THE SCHERER DOES
NOT HAVE THAT SAME INTENT AND
THEY HAD SOME COMMENTARY THAN
THEIR OWN ORIGINAL CONTENT. SO
HOW DO YOU HOW DO YOU SEE THESE
QUESTIONS- THESE ISSUES BEING
RESOLVED. BUT THE LAW
ESSENTIALLY- PASSED THE TECH
COMPANY ORDER FORM TO DISCLOSE
WHETHER OR NOT THEY HOW SUCH A
POLICY. SO IT DOESN'T REALLY
MANDATE THE CONTENT. OF THE
POLICY ITSELF- OR DOES IT. NEED
A DOES IT COMPELS SPEECH SHELF
EXAMPLE IT ALL DEPENDS ON THE
DEFINITION OF- LET'S SAY- OF
THIS PATIENT. YES. IT
DEFINITION THAT'S OUT OF
ACCEPTED BY ALL PARTIES THAT
BUT- I DO UNDERSTAND YOUR
CONCERN BUT YOU KNOW THE- THE
INTENT HERE IS TO FIND. A TO
FIND THE LOWEST- COMMON
DENOMINATOR DOT WOULD BASICALLY
FIT. ON THE DEFINITION OF THE
DEFINITION OF MISINFORMATION
ACROSS THE BOARD. ARE THERE ARE
A LITTLE OVER TWO HUNDRED OR
THERE ABOUT TWO HUNDRED SOCIAL
MEDIA PLATFORMS OUT THERE. AND
SOME OF THE PLATFORM STATE YOU
HAVE POLICIES SOME DELL SO THAT
YOUR INTENT IS TO BASICALLY
CREATE ONE UNIFORM POLICY. I
WOULD ALLOW ALL PLATFORMS TO
COMPLY WITH. AND OF SO. SO
TAXES EXACTLY WHAT WE WORKING
ON THE DEFINITION OF. OKAY I
MEAN I DON'T SEE LIKE HUGE
PROBLEM I GUESS THE IDEA OF
DISCLOSURE BUT IT IT KIND OF
SEEMS LIKE THIS MIGHT BE THE
FIRST STEP DOWN HE ROAD MAYBE.
AT TRYING TO ADD MORE. CLOSELY
MONITOR YEAH AND- AND YOU KNOW
REQUIRE A SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS TO MONITOR- THEIR
CONTENT FOR. FOR FAKE NEWS- AND
I SO I GUESS MY POINT IS THAT
THE- SAFEGUARDS THAT WE'VE
RECOGNIZED AS NECESSARY TO
PREVENT- YOU CRIMINALIZING YOU
KNOW FALSE STATEMENTS- FROM.
UNDULY BURDENING SPEECH- IT.
MIGHT NOT BE WORKABLE IN THE
CONTEXT- THAT WE'RE DEALING
WITH HERE. AND SO I JUST THINK
THAT- THAT'S SOMETHING TO BE
MINDFUL OF BEFORE WE GO TOO FAR
DOWN THIS ROAD I DO GET IT. AND
THE DEFINITION WAS ACTUALLY
TAKEN FROM. OUT OF THE VERBIAGE
THAT'S BEING USED BY OTHER-
SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS AS WELL
SO THEY'RE PRETTY MUCH ALIGN
WITH WHAT'S OUT THERE AS FAR AS
THE DEFINITION ISN'T.
DEFINITIONS CONCERT BUT I DON'T
KNOW FOUGHT FOR SYSTEMS AS
ANYTHING TO ADD TO THAT. SO
JUST NINETY I COULD ASK SINCE
ARE YOU STILL. THERE YES I. AT
THAT YOU FOR THE UP. TO VOTE ON
THIS I DO THINK IT'S REALLY.
THAT THIS STATUTE IS NOT
ATTEMPTING TO DO WHAT WILL GIVE
A CALL. IT'S JUST A EXACT WHAT.
A THE AFTER. WITH OF. FALSE
INFORMATION THAT'S BEING
DISSEMINATED BROUGHT SO THE
ONLY THING THAT'S DAHLE WE IN
THIS BILL IS TO REQUIRE THAT
THE PLOT HAS TO INFORM ITS
CUSTOMERS- IT WAS THEY'RE USING
IT ALL WHETHER IT HAS A POLICY
OR NOT I AND OF COURSE THE
RIVER SENATE AND I CERTAINLY
AGREE- THAT THE POTENTIAL
CONSTITUTIONAL ISSUES THAT
COULD COME UP WAY WAY DOWN THE
ROAD COULD BE INVOLVED BECAUSE
MOST FUNDAMENTALLY THE FIRST
AMENDMENT DOESN'T RESTRICT. THE
CONDUCT OF PRIVATE PARTIES ONLY
DEALS WITH THE GOVERNMENT SO TO
THE EXTENT THAT THERE'S A
CONCERN HERE IT'S IN A WAY BACK
GENERATED BY THE FACT THAT WE
DON'T WE DON'T OF THE NORMAL
REGULATORY PROCESS IS A PLACE
BECAUSE PRIVATE COMPANIES THEN
IF PRIVATE PUMP START ACTING
ALMOST LIKE THE GUY AND THEY
START CENSORING EACH AND REALLY
EXPRESS WAY I THEN THAT RAY
REALLY IMPORT POLICY. BUT BUT
THIS BILL IS BACK ABOUT FOUR
STEPS WE GET TO THE PROBLEM
AREA BECAUSE ALWAYS REQUIRING
IS THE NOT THE IT PLATFORM
WOULD HAVE HAVE A POLICY THEY
JUST HAVE TO INFORM. THOSE WHO.
WITH EVERY STATE TO CARE ABOUT
IT WHETHER THEY HAVE A POLICY
HERE NOT. AND THE CON. AT LEAST
NOW STONE UP TO THAT. THANK YOU
CODE. OKAY THANK YOU DRESS.
THANK YOU MR TRUMP THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL I THINK
THAT IS MISTER KILEY SAID THIS
IS THE FIRST STEP AND WE DO
HAVE TO MOVE IN THIS DIRECTION
BECAUSE AS YOU MENTIONED IN THE
STATISTICS THERE ARE SO MANY
PEOPLE RELYING ON SOCIAL MEDIA
TO GET THEIR NEWS AND
OFTENTIMES THERE ON TROOPS
THEIR FALSE STATEMENTS
KNOWINGLY MADE FALSE STATEMENTS
SO I THINK THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
FIRST STEP AND I MOVE THE BILL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU YOU HAVE A
MOTION IS THEIR SECOND. THANK
YOU YOU HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND TO GALLAGHER. YEAH THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND SO
NUMBER CHAO I KNOW YOU AND I
BOTH. CARE VERY MUCH ABOUT. THE
PROBLEM OF MISINFORMATION BUT
WE APPROACH THIS IN TWO
DIFFERENT WAYS RIGHT SO. YOU
KNOW FOR ME ONE OF MY BIG
CONCERNS HAS BEEN THE ACTUAL
CENSORSHIP THAT WE ALREADY
SEEN. ON SOCIAL MEDIA AND THE
WAY THAT I APPROACH THIS IS I
THINK THAT ACTUALLY- MORE
SPEECH. IS WHAT ENDS UP.
EXPOSING THINGS FALSE AND
THEORIES- AND SHOWING THAT
THINGS ARE NOT ACCURATE MORE
SPEECH HELPS. BRING THAT OUT-
AND DISPEL THE MYTHS THAT ARE
OUT THERE- RATHER THAN LAST
SPEECH AND RATHER THAN AND
SUPPRESSING SPEECH- AND I DO I
WORRY THAT. NUMBER ONE I WORRY
ABOUT THE TECH COMPANIES
THEMSELVES THE SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS THEMSELVES YOU KNOW I
HAD LEGISLATION THAT WAS
FOCUSED ON NOT ALLOWING THEM TO
CENSOR SOMETHING. WE BASED ON
THE POLITICAL NATURE OF THE
SPEECH AND THERE HAVE BEEN
SEVERAL INSTANCES WHERE THAT
APPEARS TO BE THE CASE THAT IT
WAS MORE ABOUT THE VIEWPOINT OF
THE PERSON BRINGING THAT THEN
WHETHER OR NOT AND- YOU KNOW IT
WAS. ACCURATE OR OR OR
CERTAINLY LIKE TO THE FORMS OF
SPEECH THAT THE CONSTITUTION AS
SET ARE LESS PROTECTED
OBSCENITY. YOU KNOW CERTAINLY.
CALLS TO VIOLENCE AGAINST
PEOPLE THINGS LIKE THAT
IMMEDIATE ACTS OF VIOLENCE
AGAINST A PERSON'S IN GROUPS-
BUT LARGELY I THINK WE NEED TO
TRY AND KEEP A FREE MARKET OF
SPEECH BECAUSE THAT SEEMS TO
SUPPRESS ENOUGH AND I'LL I'LL
GIVE AN EXAMPLE OF THEM. I
THINK IT REALLY WE REALLY SEEN
THAT IT WORKS WHEN IT COMES. TO
MAJOR PUBLIC FIGURES FOR
INSTANCE JUST YESTERDAY YOU
KNOW PRESIDENT TRUMP WITH HAD
TWEETED ABOUT JOE SCARBOROUGH.
AND PERHAPS IN BEING INVOLVED
WITH THE DEATH OF ONE OF HIS
INSURANCE AND IT WAS
IMMEDIATELY CALLED OUT BY
ALMOST ALL THE NEWS AND- AND
ALL DIFFERENT PEOPLE SAYING
THAT AS A CONSPIRACY THEORY
THAT HAS BEEN PROVEN FALSE.
IT'S ALMOST IMMEDIATELY JUMPED
ON AND THE MARKET OF FREE
SPEECH. BASICALLY CALLED THAT
OUT RIGHT AND I THINK WE CAN
LOOK TO MANY DIFFERENT CASES
WHERE THAT IS BEEN. THE CASE-
WHERE WE WHERE WE SEEM TO HAVE
SOME PROBLEM- IS REALLY AND
EXAMPLE BOX THAT ARE OUT THERE-
THIS WAS. MOST OF THE CALLED
OUT THE MODEL REPORT FOR THE
MOVE PART SAID THAT THESE
RUSSIA BOUGHT. WHAT THEY WERE
DOING IS THEY WERE ACTUALLY
POSING AS FOR EXAMPLE A BLACK
LIVES MATTER GROUP WHERE THEY
WERE POSING AS A TEA PARTY.
GROUP AND THEY WERE STILL KEEN
REALLY THE FIRE. AND STOKING
THE INDIVIDUAL- PASSIONS OF
THESE GROUPS- USING FALSE
NARRATIVES THAT WEREN'T EVEN
ACTUALLY TRUE BUT THEY GOT THAT
GROUP. TO BE ANIMATED
IMMOBILIZED- THOSE ARE THOSE
ARE THE AREAS WHERE IT'S MORE
SURREPTITIOUS WHERE. YOU WANT
SPEECH TO BE ABLE TO CALL THOSE
THINGS OUT AND I GUESS TO MY
COLLEAGUES POINT ABOUT. LOOK
MANY MORE PEOPLE ARE LOOKING AT
SOCIAL MEDIA AGAIN THEIR NEWS
THERE BUT WHOSE RESPONSIBILITY
IS IT. TO EDUCATE THEMSELVES.
AND TO BE PUBLICLY INFORMED
IT'S THE PER IS THE INDIVIDUAL
AND- THAT YOU SHOULD BE LOOKING
AT DIFFERENT VIEW POINT YOU
SHOULD BE YOU SHOULD BE EXPOSED
YOU SHOULD BE EXPOSED TO MANY
DIFFERENT. YOU SHOULD JUST
LISTEN TO FOX NEWS OR YOU
SHOULD JUST LISTEN TO CNN.
RIGHT SAID TO ME THE ANSWER IS
MORE SPEECH IT'S AS AND NOT
FINDING WAYS ACTUALLY SUPPRESS
BEACH AND MY CONCERN WITH YOUR
BILLS YEAH THE FIRST LEVEL IT'S
JUST ASKING THEM TO SAY DO WE
HAVE A POLICY. BUT WE ALREADY
KNOW THAT THERE'S BILLS BY
SENATOR PAN FOR EXIT FOR
EXAMPLE THEY'RE LOOKING TO HAVE
A PLAN TO TELL YOU KNOW PLAN A
FRAMEWORK FOR HOW SPEECH SHOULD
BE HANDLED ON THESE PLATFORMS
AND I BELIEVE THAT'S GOING TO
LEAD TO MORE SUPPRESSION WERE
ALREADY SEEN IT ON THE
PLATFORMS THEMSELVES. WHERE
THEY'RE CENSORING SPEECH. AND
THE MORE THE GOVERNMENT GETS
INVOLVED I GET REALLY CONCERNED.
BECAUSE IN GOVERNMENT STARTS
DETERMINING BASED ON THEIR
PLAN- BASED ON SOME DEFINITION
THAT WE MIGHT COME UP WITH.
WHAT CONSTITUTES TRUE NEWS AND
FAKE NEWS AND IT'S NOT THE
GOVERNMENT'S PLACE TO DO THAT
IT REALLY IS NOT- AND THE
PROBLEM WITH THAT IS THAT THE
GOVERNMENT CAN BEGIN THE USE
THAT POWER TO SUPPRESS
LEGITIMATE VIEWPOINTS ONCE A
DAY DON'T AGREE WITH SUB SUB
SUPPRESS CRITICISM EVEN
GOVERNMENT AND I'M A PROFESSOR
SIMS YOU KNOW YOU BROUGHT THAT
UP THAT. DOWN THE ROAD THIS
COULD BECOME MORE OF A PROBLEM.
I BELIEVE THAT. THE SOCIAL
MEDIA PLATFORMS HAVE BECOME
MUCH MORE LIKE A LIMITED PUBLIC
FORUM WHICH THERE HAS BEEN CASE
LAW SAYING LOOK IN LIMIT PUBLIC
FORMS YOU HAVE TO ALLOW FOR
FREE SPEECH AND THE EVEN THOUGH
THESE ARE PRIVATE AREAS. THESE
ARE PRIVATE COMPANIES BECAUSE
THESE NOW HAVE BECOME A FORM
I'LL GIVE AN EXAMPLE WHEN I WAS
ON THE BERKELEY CAMPUS AS AN
UNDERGRADUATE. THERE WAS NOT IT
IN SPROUT PLAZA THERE WAS ALL
KINDS OF YOU POINTS. BEING
EXPRESSED OUT THERE AND I WOULD
SAY THERE'S EVEN THINGS THAT I
WOULD SAY THAT IS. THAT'S FALSE
IS NOT EVEN TRUE RIGHT. AND
YET. BECAUSE THAT WAS A PUBLIC
FORUM WHERE PEOPLE HAVE THE
RIGHT TO SAY YOU KNOW THE BIRTH
OF THE FREE SPEECH MOVEMENT. WE
DIDN'T TRY TO SUPPRESS. PEOPLE
SPEECH- WE USED OUR SPEECH TO
SAY HEY HERE'S WHAT WE BELIEVE
IN HERE'S WHAT WE THINK IS TRUE.
AND I BELIEVE THAT FOR IS THE
ULTIMATE DISINFECTANT IS THE
ULTIMATE. TRUTH TELLER BECAUSE-
TRUTH WILL OF TRUTH WILL
EVENTUALLY RISE. TO THE TOP IT
AMONG SAYS IT WILL IT WILL CALL
OUT THINGS ARE FALSE AND SO
THAT I MEAN ALL THAT TO SAY. I
DID I DID I GET CONCERNED WERE
MOVING TOO FAR INTO THE SPACE
FOR ACTUALLY GONNA ALTERNATELY
SUPPRESS LEGITIMATE VIEW POINTS
WE'RE GOING TO WEAR THIS COULD
BE THE FOCUS OF. SUPPRESSING
SPEECH- I NECESSARILY I THINK
WE'RE ALL WORRIED ABOUT YOU
KNOW PEOPLE. LOOK I MEAN PEOPLE
LISTEN TO A VARIETY OF
VIEWPOINTS AND PEOPLE ARE
ENTITLED TO BE WRONG. PEOPLE
ARE ENTITLED TO. YOU KNOW
BELIEVE THE THINGS THAT THEY
WANT TO BELIEVE THAT'S KIND OF
A FUNDAMENTAL CORNERSTONE OF
THIS COUNTRY AND IF THE
GOVERNMENT STARTS GETTING TOO
FAR INTO THAT WILL WE'RE GOING
TO TEACH PEOPLE WHAT THEY
BELIEVE THEM NO MORE NOT. THE
AMERICA THAT I KNOW. AT THE END
OF THAT THIS IS WHAT YOU NEED
TO KNOW AND IF YOU DON'T
BELIEVE THIS AND YOU'RE
SOMEHOW. WRONG AND I'VE BUT I
WORRY ABOUT GOING DOWN. A PAST
LIKE THAT SO I MEAN. HAPPY TO
HAVE YOU RESPOND TO THAT AND
GIVE ME YOUR THOUGHTS BUT-
THAT'S MY CONCERN. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER GALLAGHER FOR
COMMENTS- LET LET ME SAY THIS I
DO AGREE WITH YOU THAT WE
SHOULD NOT SUPPRESS. A SPEECH
WHATSOEVER BECAUSE WE THAT'S
WHAT THE FIRST AMENDMENT IS ALL
ABOUT THAT. AND THIS PARTICULAR
MEASURE DOES NOT SUPPRESS
SPEECH- AS MENTIONED BY
PROFESSOR SAM AND- AND IT DOES
NOT. EITHER ENCOURAGE OR
DISCOURAGE SPEECH. IT DOES NOT-
COMPELS SPEECH. ARE WE DID
MENTION A WORD I THINK ON A
KIND OF. PIGGY BACK ON THAT AND
THAT IS SO I THINK. OFTENTIMES
WE NEED TO KIND OF. A SEEK A
BALANCE BETWEEN. OF CORPORATE
RESPONSIBLE FOR COMPANY
RESPONSIBILITY SOCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY. WHAT LET'S SEE
WHAT THE USERS OUT THERE NEED.
AT THIS DAY AND AGE I THINK
PEOPLE UP THERE ARE HUNGRY FOR
INFORMATION AND THAT'S WHAT
SOCIAL MEDIA IS PROVIDING. THE
PROBLEM IS A LOT OF SENSE TIONS
SIR RATED. NOW WHAT JUST ONE.
THIS DOES IS ESSENTIALLY AS
MENTIONED EARLIER ONLY TO WE-
DOT PLOT FOR TO DISCLOSE
WHETHER THEY- ARE THEY HAVE
SUCH A POLICY. TO ADDRESS THE
ISSUE OF MISINFORMATION. DOES
NOT IS CONTENT NEUTRAL IT IS
SAW TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL. SO
THAT'S WHY WE DON'T HAVE ANY
FIRST DIMINISH IT NOW. AS TO
YOUR FEAR ABOUT YOU KNOW GOING
TO STEP TO STEP FORWARD I MEAN
THAT'S IN THE FUTURE I MEAN. I
DO NOT INTEND TO GO ANY FURTHER
THAN THIS AT LEAST FOR THE
MOMENT. SO I THINK IT'S A
BALANCING ACT BETWEEN LET'S SAY
OF. CORPORATE RESPONSIBILITY TO
OUR SOCIETY AND WHAT THE USERS.
NEED TO KNOW BECAUSE THESE
USERS OF JUST LAY PEOPLE STATE
THEY DON'T KNOW ANY DIDN'T THEY
DON'T HAVE A LOT OF A LOT OF
SOPHISTICATION WHEN IT COMES TO
FAKE NEWS FOR EXAMPLE. SO HOW
WOULD THEY DISCERN WHAT IS TRUE
AND WHAT IS NOT TRUE. SO THAT
HAS TO BE DOLLARS WHICH- THE
PLATFORMS SOCIAL RESPONSIBILITY
HOW MUCH DID THEY DO. YOU KNOW
IN THIS EQUATION. TO DATE FACT
CHECK SHOULD THEY REMOVE THE
CONTENT WELL SHOULD THEY JUST
DO A DISCLOSURE AND THAT'S WHAT
THIS BILL DOES IT'S A SIMPLE
DISCLOSURE BILL. SO I DON'T
KNOW PROFESSOR SINCE YOU YOU
LIKE TO RESPOND TO THAT AS I
THINK WE'RE- WE GET. THE AD
THEY WERE GOOD AT THIS POINT I
WAS MORE OF A STATEMENT BY
MISTER GALLAGHER THAN. A
QUESTION ULTIMATELY MISTER
OBERNOLTE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR OF. MR CHOW I PRECIADO
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO HERE I
HAVE SOME CONCERNS WITH. THE
LANGUAGE. THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT BECAUSE- YOU KNOW WE
COULD HAVE A PHILOSOPHICAL
AGREEMENT THAT SOMETHING IS BAD
AND WE WANT TO STOP THE SPREAD
OF THIS INFORMATION ON SOCIAL
MEDIA. BUT THE LANGUAGE THAT WE
CHOOSE TO USE MATTERS BECAUSE
WE'RE WRITING THE WALKING. SO
THE U. YOU'VE- BEEN VERY CLEAR
THAT YOU'RE NOT ATTEMPTING TO
REQUIRE CERTAIN CONTENT OF THE
POLICY YOU JUST WANT TO-
REQUIRE THAT A DISCLOSURE ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT HE POLICY EXISTS
IS THAT RIGHT THAT'S CORRECT
OKAY SO- IF THE POLICY WAS-WE
THINK WE DON'T CURATE THIS
PLATFORM USE IT AT YOUR OWN
RISK BUT IS THAT. IT AND YOU
JUST CLOSE THAT THERE IS A
POLICY IS THAT IMPLANTS OF WITH
THIS BILL THAT'S OF ISIS WHAT
FOR THE SAKE OF THIS LAW OKAY
BUT SO WHAT IF YOUR CAR IF
THAT'S CASE WHAT THE OUR
PURPOSE FOR THE U. OUT THERE TO
THIS. WHICH OF THESE PLATFORMS
I DO HAVE A POLICY WE FATE NEW
OR VISIT SO DATE COULD BE THE
ARE THE YOU KNOW THE COULD PICK
AND CHOOSE WHICH HAVE A FIVE
THE RIGHT TO GET ON LOOK AT THE
PHARMACY I JUST JUST IS JUST NO
BECAUSE IT'S PLATFORM A
SPECIFICALLY. THE WE DON'T
THINK APOLLO TO SIR THAT'S UP
TO THE PLATFORM ITSELF. THE
BUTTON. IS SO I MEAN IT IS A
USER OF THE- I SEE THAT HAVE
THE POWER. TO THE- SPREAD OF IN
A- AND BUT THE POLICIES
ACTUALLY SAYING THAT THEY DON'T
HAVE A- SO OFTEN ABOUT IS THAT
HOW HOW GAME TO A USER OF THE-
WELL IT. IF THEY DON'T HAVE A-
TO YOU KNOW. THAT THE- LETTER
DOUBLE BEWARE I GUESS THE
CUSTOMER. THAT I MEAN IF THE
USER. STILL WANTS TO USE OUR
PLATFORM THAT'S UP ON KNOW THAT
THEIR OWN FOR OUR- WE NOT SEE.
THIS PART ON THE NUMBER POLICY.
USE THAT WE'RE NOT SAYING I
WHATSOEVER. SO THIS IS TO HELP
THE- TO BASIC GIVE US A
GUIDANCE AS TO WHICH- DOES.
HAVE A POP. FOR JUST ISSUE
WHICH- PROVIDES. BUT WE DO WILL
GIVE THEM NO GUIDE SOMETIMES I
DON'T TO GET A- CALL IF WE HEAR.
SEC BUT I MEAN IF YOU SEE MY-
RIGHT. WELL IF THE POLICY.
AMOUNT THIS WE DON'T THINK NEED
A POLL. IN WE'RE SAYING THE
THAT'S UP. AND THEN I'M JUST
AND PEOPLE YES WE HAVE A POT.
HOW IS THAT GIVING ME ANY
USEFUL INFORMATION A USER
PLATFORM. THAT WOULD PROBABLY
WHAT JUST HAPPENED. DOWN GIVE
TO YOU. NO MORE SURE AND SAYS
TO THE COME. YOU DOING.
BUSINESS OKAY I DON'T SEE THAT
IT DOES. MEAN THAT THAT'S WHAT
THAT'S- I DO THINK THAT THE-
YOU KNOW IN THIS WHOLE DEBATE.
THERE THERE MERIT. TO BE
INACCURATE. YOU KNOW IF I PUT A
STATE WITH ITS- I CAN SAY MAN
IS GOOD. ON MY FACEBOOK PAGE IS
THAT AN ACCURATE WELL SOME
PEOPLE WOULD ARGUE THAT IT IS.
IT ALL IT'S ACTUALLY VERY
DIFFICULT THING. TO PROVE
DEFINITIVELY THAT'S ACCURATE OR
INACCURATE. I MEAN WHAT ONCE
YOU GET ONCE YOU START TO SLICE
DOWN ON IT JUST ENDS UP BEING.
THE THIS HUGE PROBLEM. AND WE
END UP HAVING TO COME BACK DOWN
THE SIDE OF FREE SPEECH AND
SAYING OKAY LOOK. WE UNDERSTAND
THAT WHEN PEOPLE POST
SOMETHING. IT IS THEIR OPINION.
AND YOU KNOW IF YOU'RE GOING TO
RELY ON IT IS FACT IT'S YOUR
RESPONSIBILITY TO GO FACT CHECK
AND THAT THEN THAT'S WHERE WE
ARE NOW. WITH WITH I'M HERE FOR
VERY GOOD REASON. SO THOSE ARE
MY CONCERNS WITH THE BILL I
JUST. I DON'T SEE THAT. THAT
THIS IS MAKING MEANINGFUL STEPS
IN THE DIRECTION IS GOING TO
SOLVE THE ACTUAL PRODUCT. HI
WHAT YOU'RE COMING FROM BUT I
DO DISAGREE. BUT I THINK THAT'S
WHAT THEY'RE- IN A MINUTE.
FOREST HELP AS WELL. OFFERS HOW
DO YOU INTERPRET CASE LAW AND-
SO FORTH. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
FOR MORE I AM THREE HOUR. SO I
WAS JUST READING AND I KNOW
YOU'RE CHANGE THE DEFINITION
BUT YOU KNOW AS AS THINGS ARE
NOW. WE'RE ASKING THEM TO WHAT
IS OUR POLICY TO ADDRESS THE
SPREAD OF MISINFORMATION
INCLUDING INACCURATE CONTENT
REPORTED AS FACT. DECEPTICON
UNAIDED AND DECEPTIVE PROMOTION
OR SUPPRESSION OF INFORMATION.
AND PRACTICES INTENDED TO
MANIPULATE OR DESTRUCTIVE
BEHAVIOR OF USERS. ON SOCIAL
MEDIA PRO WHAT DO WE GET DO
WITH CAMPAIGNS. THIS GOT YOUR
MASK IN ORDER TO MAKE IT AND
SORRY NEEDLE THERE. WHAT ARE WE
GOING TO DO WITH POLITICAL
CAMPAIGNS AND POLITICAL SPEECH
RIGHT BECAUSE I THINK A LOT OF
PEOPLE SAY AND THE COURSE OF
THE CAMPAIGN THERE'S THINGS
THAT ARE- THAT MAKE A LOT OF
DEPEND ON WHAT SIDE YOU'RE ON
HE WOULD SAY. HEY THOSE ARE-
NOT QUITE ACCURATE THERE YOU
BEING USED TO MANIPULATE THEIR
BEING USED TO PROMOTE. ARE
BEING USED TO SUPPRESS
SOMETHING ELSE. HOW CERTAINLY
POLITICAL SPEECH IS PROTECTED
SPEECH RIGHT HOW WE GONNA DO
WITH THAT OR HOW DO YOU PROPOSE
THE SOCIAL MEDIA. PLATFORM TO
DEAL WITH THAT I'M GONNA GIVE
YOU A SHORT ANSWER AND THEN I
WANTED TO FOR TO- PROFESSOR THE
SHORT ANSWER IS OUT THAT PART
OF THE DEFINITION IS STILL BE
PARKED ON. SO WITH THAT- CAN I
REFER TO AS- PROFESSOR SAM JUST
FOR QUICK YES PROFESSOR SIMPLY
VERY OF SOMETHING TO ADD TO
THAT BRIEFLY HAVE ANYTHING
SURE I WOULD JUST OKAY IN TERMS
OF THE FIRST MANY CATEGORIES.
THE MOST TROUBLING OR IS OUR
CONTENT BASED REGULATION AND OF
COURSE WE KNOW EVEN THERE ARE
SOME CONTENT PASTE REGULATIONS
OKAY IF YOU'RE DEALING WITH
LIFE ALERT YOU'RE DEALING WITH
OBSCENITY. CHILD **** THIS BILL
IS WAY BACK FROM THAT BOUNDARY
BECAUSE IT'S NOT DEALING WITH
THE CONTENT AT ALL IT'S
REQUIRING. PROVIDER OF A
CERTAIN SERVICE TO MAKE CERTAIN
DISCLOSURE THOSE USING THE
PLATFORM. AND IT'S I BELIEVE
WELL DESIGNED TO LET PEOPLE
FIGURE OUT. TO SOME DEGREE HOW
MUCH RELIANCE TAKING PLACE AND
WHAT THEY SEE YOU KNOW IF THEY
KNOW THAT THERE'S NO POLICY WE
DON'T CENSOR THIS MATURE WE
DON'T LOOK AT IT AT ALL
ANYTHING GO WELL THEN. MOST
PEOPLE WOULD BE MORE CAUTIOUS
IN. LOOKING AT THE JOB THEY'RE
DECIDING WHETHER IT'S CREDIT.
RIGHT THANK YOU MISTER JOHN
HAPPY TO SUPPORT YOUR BILL
TODAY BECAUSE OF WHAT IT
ACTUALLY SAYS NOT WHAT. FEARFUL
IT IT MIGHT SAY DOWN THE LINE
AND I AGREE IT'S JUST A NOTICE
BILL. AND WHETHER A PLATFORM
HAS A POLICY EXPLICITLY OF NOT
TOUCHING ANY OF THIS WAR HAS A
MORE NUANCED POLICY THAT IS
INFORMATION TO THE END USER
BECAUSE IT END USER ESPECIALLY
THINK OF IT IN THE CONTEXT OF.
THE PARENTS HELPING A CHILD
DECIDE. HOW TO FILTER. WHAT IS
COMING OFF OF A OF A WEBSITE
WELL WORLD OF A SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORM THE INFORMATION THAT
THERE IS. NO CONCERN FOR
FILTERING AT ALL ON THAT. TOP
PLATFORM OR THAT THERE IS SOME
I THINK IS VERY USEFUL. THE
BECAUSE- THE INFORMATION COMING
OUT OF THIS BROAD THING THAT WE
CALL THE INTERNET IS SO
PROLIFIC IT IS SO RIGHT ONE OF
THE BIGGEST CHALLENGES I THINK
WE HAVE AS A SOCIETY IS
FILTERING INFORMATION WE HAVE.
AND I ACTUALLY WISH THAT. THE
INDUSTRY WOULD COME UP WITH.
DISCLOSURE THE BULLS THAT MAKE
IT EASIER FOR A USER TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE RISK MAY OR
MAY NOT BE WITH RESPECT TO THAT
SITE AND THAT'S WHAT I THINK
YOU WERE ATTEMPTING TO DO AND I
APPRECIATE THAT YOU WORKING OUT
BECAUSE THE DEFINITIONS OR
REALLY GOING TO MATTER IN HERE
AND I THINK IF THIS WAS GOING
TO IN FACT REGULATORS STEP INTO
REGULATIONS BECAUSE I AGREE
THAT THAT IS A KIND OF A
DANGEROUS PLACE TO GO BUT I
THINK IT'S VERY USEFUL FOR A
USER OF. ANY PLATFORM. TO HAVE
A COMMUNICATION FROM WHOEVER'S
RUNNING THAT PLATFORM TO SAY
OUR POLICY IS NO POLICY WHICH
IS A POLICY OR OUR POLICY IS
THESE GUIDELINES WHICH IS A
MORE. ENUMERATED POLICY THAT'S
INFORMATION THAT THAT A USER
CAN BE USED TO DECIDE WHETHER
OR NOT THEY WANT TO INTERACT OR
HOPEFULLY. TO FILTER THE
INFORMATION THAT THEY'RE
GETTING SO THAT BECAUSE THE
USER DOES NEED TO TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR WHAT THEY DO
WITH THAT INFORMATION. THE MORE
THEY UNDERSTAND ABOUT THE
VERACITY FOR THE CONTROLS THAT
MAY OR MAY NOT BE THERE ARE NOT
THAT I'M SUGGESTING WE PUT
CONTROLS ON THERE BECAUSE I
THINK THAT THAT BECOMES
TROUBLING. BUT AT LEAST A
STATEMENT. THAT IS COMMON
ACROSS PLATFORMS SO THAT TE
USER HAS AN ABILITY TO SAY.
OKAY I'M GONNA BE GETTING
ANYTHING AND EVERYTHING HERE
BECAUSE THERE ARE NO CONTROLS
OVER FALSE INFORMATION OR
THERE'S AT LEAST AN ATTEMPT. TO
CONTROL FALSE INFORMATION THIS
IS WHAT IT IS. THEN THE USER
COULD DECIDE I AGREE WITH THAT
OR AYE THOSE CONTROLS OR I
DISAGREE WITH THOSE CONTROLS
AND MAKE A DECISION AND THAT'S
WHAT I THINK IS IMPORTANT AND
THAT'S WHY THIS IS APPROPRIATE
AT THIS POINT BECAUSE IT IS
JUST A NOTIFICATION WE'RE
ASKING. THE PLATFORMS TO SAY
WHAT IT IS YOU DO SO THAT THE
END USER HAS BETTER INFORMATION.
TO MAKE A DECISION ON WHETHER
OR NOT THEY'RE GOING TO RELY ON
THAT INFORMATION OR WHAT
THEY'RE GOING TO DO. WITH THAT
THAT SITE WERE THAT PLATFORM.
SO I THINK THIS IS APPROPRIATE
AT THIS POINT THIS WOULD BE
USEFUL INFORMATION. AND THERE
ARE OTHER AREAS I THINK THAT
THE INDUSTRY COULD DO A BETTER
JOB OF INFORMING CONSUMERS
ABOUT WHAT THEY DO WITH
INFORMATION THAT WOULD LEAD TO
CONSUMERS MAKING BETTER
DECISIONS THAT MAYBE AYBE NOT.
BUT I WOULD HOPE THAT THEY
WOULD IT WOULD BE USEFUL IN
THAT CONTEXT SO I THAT I
APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE DOING
HERE I ALSO APPRECIATE THAT
YOURE WORKING WITH THE
OPPOSITION BECAUSE THOSE
DEFINITIONS ULTIMATELY ARE
GOING TO BE IMPORTANT. IN HOW A
USER DECIDES. HOW TO FILTER
WHAT THEY'RE GETTING BASED ON
THE INFORMATION THAT THIS IS
GOING TO ASK. FOLKS TO PUT
FORWARD AND WE ARE SO FAR I
THINK WE'RE SO FAR AWAY FROM.
ANY CONSTITUTIONAL QUESTION.
THAT THIS IS PERFECTLY
APPROPRIATE FOR. OUR COMMITTEE.
SO WITH THAT THE STRAP. YOU MAY
CLOSE THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
JUST I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
WE'RE I'VE OFTEN THANKS FOR THE
COMMENTS AS WELL. THANK YOU WE
DO HAVE A MOTION TO SECOND.
THAT MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
STONE BY STONE AYE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NOT VOTING. CHAU HI
SO I TO AND SALAS HOLDEN KALRA
KALRA AYE KILEY. KILEY NO
MAIENSCHEIN OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE
NO REYES AS I. THAT HAS FOUR
VOTES OKAY I WILL PUT THE BILL
ON CALL THEN WITH FOUR VOTES
THANK YOU MISTER THOMAS REYES
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER
FOUR AB. TWENTY FOUR FORTY FIVE
OPERATOR YOU CAN OPEN THE LINES
FOR AB. TWENTY FOUR FORTY FIVE.
THE LINES ARE OPEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS%
ARE TODAY PRESENT AB TWENTY
FOUR FORTY FIVE WHICH WILL
EXTEND THAT TO LEGAL GUARDIANS
THE RIGHT TO BRING A CLAIM ON
BEHALF OF THEIR CHILD IF THE
CHILD PASSES AWAY TO THE WRONG
DUE TO THE WRONGFUL CONDUCT OF
ANOTHER STAND AT THE ASSUMING
THE CHILD HAS NO LIVING PARENTS.
CURRENT LAW SPECIFIES THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO MAY BRING A
CAUSE OF ACTION FOR THE DEATH
OF A PERSON. COST BY THE
WRONGFUL ACT OR NEGLECT OF
ANOTHER. THESE INDIVIDUALS ARE
LIMITED TO THE DECEDENT'S
SPOUSE. CHILDREN AND IN THE
ABSENCE OF THESE INDIVIDUALS
THOSE WHO WOULD BE ENTITLED TO
THE PROPERTY OF DECEDENT
INCLUDING THE PARENTS.
SPECIFICALLY A MINOR PASSES
AWAY DUE TO THE WRONGFUL
CONDUCT OF OTHERS AND THE
MINERS ON MARRIED AND DOES NOT
HAVE CHILDREN. THAN THOSE WHO
CAN BRING FORTH THE CASE OR THE
MINERS BIOLOGICAL OR ADOPTIVE
PARENTS. BUT NOT EVERY CHILD IS
RAISED BY THEIR PARENTS. IF THE
MINERS REYES BY LEGAL GUARDIANS
WHO HAVE NOT OFFICIALLY ADOPTD
THE MINOR THESE LEGAL GUARDIANS
DO NOT HAVE LEGAL STANDING TO
BRING A CLAIM IN THE EVENT OF A
WRONGFUL DEATH. EVEN THOUGH
BOTH OF THE CHILD'S BIOLOGICAL
OR ADOPTIVE PARENTS ARE
DECEASED. AB TWENTY FOUR FORTY
FIVE CORRECT THIS OVERSIGHT IN
LAW BY ALLOWING LEGAL GUARDIANS
TO BRING FORTH A WRONGFUL DEATH
CASE UNDER THE SAME CONDITIONS
WHICH A PARENT CAN BRING. UNDER
THE SAME CONDITIONS- WHICH
APPEARED CAN BRING FORTH THE
CASE FOR THEIR CHILD. BUT ONLY
WHEN THE DECEASED DECEASED
CHILD'S PARENTS HAVE ALSO
PASSED AWAY. CONTRARY TO THE
OPPOSITION'S CLAIM BECAUSE
LEGAL GUARDIANS WOULD BE ACTING
AS A CHILD'S PARENT AND
BRINGING FORTH THE CASE INSTEAD
OF THE TILES DECEASED
BIOLOGICAL OR ADOPTIVE PARENT.
THIS BILL DOES NOT INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO MAY BRING
A CASE. AB TWENTY FOUR FORTY
FIVE ALLOWS A LEGAL GUARDIAN TO
SEEK JUSTICE FOR CHILD WAS
PASSED AWAY DUE TO THE WRONGFUL
CONDUCT OF ANOTHER WHEN THE
CHILD'S PARENTS CANNOT DO SO
BECAUSE THEY ARE DECEASED. TO
QUOTE THE ANALYSIS PREPARED BY
THIS COMMITTEE. ALLOWING THE
LEGAL GUARDIAN TO BRING ACTION
IN THE SAME MANNER AS ANY OTHER
PARENT WILL UPDATE THE WRONGFUL
DEATH STATUTE. TO BETTER
REFLECT THE CURRENT REALITIES
OF LIFE. FOR THESE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY RESPECTFULLY WILL
BE ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE. NOT
TO TESTIFY TESTIFIED VIA
TELEPHONE TODAY. WE HAVE NEIL
GALLO OCT TURNING IT PRIVATE
ATTORNEY WITH TAYLOR IN RING.
AND CAP THE SAKE MORE ON WHO IS
A FAMILY LAW DIRECTOR FOR THE
NATIONAL CENTER FOR LESBIAN
RIGHTS I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW TO
THE MEMBERS THAT. THIS IS NOT A
SPONSORED BILL THIS WAS BROUGHT
ABOUT AS A RESULT OF THE CHILD
DIEGO WHO DIED WITH NO PARENTS
LIVING AND TO THE LEGAL
GUARDIANS WERE PRECLUDED FROM
FILING A CLAIM. AND MISTER
GALLO UP WILL YOU MORE ABOUT
THAT. THANK YOU WHERE DO YOU.
START SO WE DO HAVE A MOTION AS
THEIR SECOND. AND A SECOND
THANK YOU THEY DO HAVE TWO
LISTED FOLKS FOR SUPPORT NEW
YORK A LOT AND KATHY SYCAMORE
ARE. YOU ON THE LINE PLEASE.
NEIL KILOWATT CAN EVERYONE HEAR
ME YES WE CAN HERE GO AHEAD
PLEASE. GOOD MORNING MEMBERS OF
THE ASSEMBLY THANK YOU FOR
GIVING ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TO ALL OF YOU ABOUT THIS
BILL BY WAY OF INTRODUCTION MY
NAME IS NEIL CAL A LOT AND I AM
A MEMBER OF THE CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO FOUR. FOUR
FIVE. I AM AN ATTORNEY AT
TAYLOR AND RING IN MANHATTAN
BEACH. WHERE I CONCENTRATE MY
PRACTICE IN THE AREAS OF
SERIOUS PERSONAL INJURY
WRONGFUL DEATH AND SEXUAL ABUSE.
ABOVE ALL AB TWO FOUR FOUR FIVE
IS ABOUT FAIRNESS THIS BILL
AIMS TO CORRECT INEQUITIES IN
THE LAW UNDER CIRCUMSTANCES
WHERE A MINOR DIES DUE TO THE
WRONGFUL CONDUCT OF OTHERS.
UNDER SUCH CIRCUMSTANCES THE
RIGHTFUL HEIRS IN A WRONGFUL
DEATH ACTION ASSUMING THE MINOR
WAS UNMARRIED AND DID NOT HAVE
CHILDREN ARE THE MINERS
PARENTS. HOWEVER IF THE MINERS
PARENTS PREDECEASED HIM OR HER
THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW FOR THE
MINERS LEGAL GUARDIANS TO WRITE
POLICE STEP INTO THE SHOES OF
THE MINERS PARENTS. AND PURSUE
WRONGFUL DEATH CLAIMS ON HIS
BEHALF. AS IT CURRENTLY STANDS.
THE LAW SAYS LEGAL GUARDIANSHIP
IS NOT ENOUGH. THE LAW REQUIRES
THE MINERS LEGAL GUARDIANS TO
HAVE FORMALLY ADOPTED THE MINOR
IN ORDER TO BRING A LAWSUIT ON
THE MINOR'S BEHALF. THIS IS A
COLORIST AND ANTIQUATED
REQUIREMENT THAT SHOULD BE
ELIMINATED AS THE LAW SHOULD
RECOGNIZE THE CHANGING NATURE
FAMILY. THIS BILL WOULD STILL
REQUIRE THESE LEGAL GUARDIANS
TO BE FORMALLY APPOINTED AT
SUCH BY THE COURT PRIOR TO THE
MINORS DEBT. THIS IS IMPORTANT
BECAUSE IT WOULD REQUIRE A
JUDICIAL OFFICER TO EVALUATE
THE CIRCUMSTANCES UNDERLYING
THE APPOINTMENT AND CONCLUDE
THAT THE PARTIES BRINGING THE
APPLICATION SHOULD IN FACT BE
APPOINTED THE MINERS LEGAL
GUARDIANS. IT SHOULD ALSO BE
NOTED THAT THIS BILL WILL NOT
EXPAND THE UNIVERSE OF
PLAINTIFFS THAT MAY PURSUE A
WRONGFUL DEATH ACTION ON BEHALF
OF A MINOR. RATHER IT MERELY
ALLOWS LEGAL GUARDIANS TO STEP
INTO THE SHOES OF THE MINERS
PARENTS WANT BOTH PARENTS HAVE
PASSED AWAY. IN SOME AB TWO
FOUR FOUR FIVE NARROWLY A MEN'S
EXISTING LAW TO ALLOW FOR THE
RIGHTFUL PROSECUTION OF
WRONGFUL DEATH ACTION. STEPPING
INTO THE SHOES OF A PARENT IS
NO EASY TASK WHEN INDIVIDUALS
TAKE ON THIS NOBLE VENTURE THEY
SHOULD BE AFFORDED THE SAME
RIGHTS AFFORDED TO THE MINORS
PARENTS. THAT JUST BRIEFLY
ABOUT THE DIEGO CASE THAT MISS
RATES MENTION THIS CASE
INVOLVES A THIRTEEN YEAR OLD
BOY WHO WAS WHO WAS BULLIED
PHYSICALLY ASSAULTED AND KILLED
AT SCHOOL. IN THE MARINO VALLEY
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
DIEGO'S PARENTS BOTH
PREDECEASED IN HIS MOTHER
PASSED AWAY WHEN HE WAS ONE
YEAR OLD. AT ITS FATHER PASSED
AWAY IN TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN.
DIEGO WAS RAISED BY HIS AUNT
AND UNCLE HIS MATERNAL AUNT AND
UNCLES IN PEOPLE'S ONE YOUR
SOUL. HE LIVES IN THE HOUSE
WITH THEM THEY TOOK CARE OF
THEM AND THEY FINANCIALLY
SUPPORTED HIM AND SO IT SEEMS
ONLY FAIR THAT GIVEN THAT THEY
WERE APPOINTED LEGAL GUARDIANS
FOR DIEGO THAT THEY ALSO BE
AFFORDED HE SAME RIGHTS THAT
DIEGO'S PARENTS WOULD HAVE BEEN
AFFORDED. AN EAGLES PARENTS
BOTH PREDECEASED. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CAMARA. THANK
YOU GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
KATHY SAKE MORA AND I'M
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT ON BEHALF
OF THE NATIONAL CENTER FOR
LESBIAN RIGHTS. NATIONAL CENTER
FOR LESBIAN RIGHTS TO THE NASH
IN A LEGAL ORGANIZATION
COMMITTED TO ADVANCING THE
CIVIL AND HUMAN RIGHTS. OF
LESBIAN GAY BISEXUAL AND
TRANSGENDER PEOPLE AND THEIR
FAMILIES. AS A PART OF OUR
MISSION WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
RIGHT TO ALL FAMILIES
REGARDLESS OF HOW THEY ARE
FORMED AND WHETHER THERE ARE
BIOLOGICAL OR ADOPTIVE FOR
LEGAL TIES. WE BELIEVE THE
LEGAL GUARDIAN SHOULD BE
INCLUDED IN WRONGFUL DEATH
ACTION BEEN ALLOWED TO PURSUE-
THESE ACTIONS IN THE CASE OF A
WRONGFUL DEATH OF THEIR CHILD
BECAUSE IN EVERY WAY THE ACTIVE
PARENTS FOR THE CHILDREN THAT
ARE IN THEIR CARE. ADDITIONALLY
WHEN CHILDREN WITH LEGAL
GUARDIANS DO NOT HAVE LEGAL
PARENTS. IN THE PICTURE AT ALL
ALL THOSE GUARDIAN SHOULD BE
PERMITTED TO PROTECTING THE
START THE RIGHTS OF THE CHILD
IF THE CHILD. IS WRONGFULLY
KILLED. LEGAL GUARDIAN ARTIST
IS AFFECTED BY THE TRAGIC DEATH
OF THE CHILD. AND THE PARENT
WOULD BE. AND FOR THESE REASONS
WE ORDER AYE VOTE. ON AB TWENTY
FOUR FOUR FIVE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT IS THERE ANYONE.
HERE THE HEARING ROOM WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY FOUR FORTY FIVE. SEEING
NONE OPERATOR OPEN UP THE LINES
FOR ANYONE WHO LIKE SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FOUR FORTY
FIVE. THANK YOU IF YOU'RE IN
SUPPORT PRESSED ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME.
AT NINE TWENTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. JANUARY
TERRACE ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU IS THERE ANY OTHER THAN
SUPPORT LEAVE AT ONE THEN ZERO
AT THE TIME. THERE ARE NO
OTHERS AT THE PORT. THANK YOU I
HAVE NO OPPOSITION LISTED IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE HEARING
ROOMWOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY FOUR
FORTY FIVE. SEEING NONE IS
THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY FOUR
FORTY FIVE. THERE IS ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION THE PERFECT ONE THEN
ZERO AT THE TIME. THERE'S NO
ONE IN OPPOSITION I THANK YOU
BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS COMMENTS WAS TO
GALLAGHER. YEAH JUST A COUPLE
QUESTIONS FOR THE AUTHOR. UNDER
UNDER YOUR BILL AS PROPOSED
WITH THE LEGAL GUARDIAN STILL
HAVE TO PROVE THAT THEY WERE
DEPENDENT ON THE DECEIT NO OKAY
SO HOW HOW DOES THAT WORK. THEY
ARE JUST THE LEGAL GUARDIAN
JUST AS THE PARENT WOULD NOT
HAVE TO PROVE THAT IS A
DIFFERENT SECTION OKAY- THAT
WAS- STATED JUST SO THAT YOU
KNOW THAT'S THE ONLY OTHER WAY
THAT THE PARENT WOULD BE ABLE
TO. TO FILE A CLAIM BUT HERE
SIMPLY BEING A PARENT ALLOWS IN
THE OPPORTUNITY AND THE RIGHT
TO FILE THE CLAIM OKAY IS THERE
ANY RESTRICTION ON DO ALL THE
OTHER. HEIRS AND- SORRY THE-
DOES THE DECEDENT STILL HAVE TO.
NOT HAVE ANY OTHER SURVIVING
PARENTS OR OTHER HEIRS. THE
DECEDENT THE DECEDENT'S LEGAL
GUARDIAN WOULD TAKE THE PLACE
OF THE PARENTS OR WHATEVER
RIGHT THE PARENTS WOULD HAVE IN
BRINGING FORTH THE LAWSUIT THAT
LEGAL GUARDIAN WOULD STEP IN
THEIR SHOES. OKAY. ARE THERE
SOME AND MAYBE SOME OF ONE OF
THE WITNESSES COULD. WHAT ARE
SOME OF THE REASONS WHY A LEGAL
GUARDIAN MIGHT NOT PROCEED WITH
ADOPTION I'M THINKING IN MOST
OF THESE CASES IS USUALLY A
CHILD INVOLVED. WHAT ARE SOME
REASONS LEGAL GUARDIAN MIGHT
NOT MOVE TOWARDS ADOPTION
BECAUSE UNDER THE CURRENT LAW
DOESN'T A DOCTOR IF. YOU CAN
BRING ROB WRONGFUL DEATH CLAIM
RIGHT. I'M SURE THERE ARE A
MYRIAD OF REASON IT MAY JUST
BE TIMING- IF- NEIL GULLIBLE
OUGHT TO IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
PROVIDE A RESPONSE IF YOU KNOW.
EIGHT AND MISTER GALLAGHER LET
ME ALSO RESPOND TO YOUR FIRST
QUESTION JUST BRIEFLY SO THE
LEGAL GUARDIAN STEP INTO THE
SHOES OF THE PARENTS THAT HAVE
THE SAME RIGHT TO SAY WHAT. IF
THE MINER WHO PASSED AWAY HAD A
SURVIVING SPOUSE OR A CHILD.
THEN UNDER THOSE CIRCUMSTANCES
THE LAW SAYS THE PARENTS COULD
ONLY BRING A CLAIM IF THEY WERE
FINANCIALLY DEPENDENT TO SOME
EXTENT. ON THE MIND. SO UNDER
THOSE CIRCUMSTANCES A LEGAL
GUARDIAN WOULD HAVE TO PROVE
FINANCIAL DEPENDENCY BUT ABSENT
A SPOUSE. OR CHILD OF THE
DECEASED MINOR THEN THE LEGAL
GUARDIANS WOULD HAVE A RIGHT TO
BRING A CLAIM JUST AS THE
PARENTS WOULD WITHOUT HAVING TO
PROVE FINANCIAL DEPEND SO IN
OTHER WORDS. THE LOFTY AND DOES
IT IS THE LEGAL GUARDIANS JUST
STEP INTO THE SHOES OF THE PAIR.
WITH RESPECT TO YOUR SECOND
QUESTION ABOUT ADOPTION I CAN
SAY THAT THERE'S AT LEAST TWO
THINGS THAT COME TO MIND ONE IS
THAT THE PROCESS CAN BE LENGTHY
AND IT CAN ALSO BE EXPENSIVE-
THERE'S A NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO.
HAVE TO GO THROUGH THAT POP
PROCESS HIGHER FAMILY LAW
ATTORNEYS- AND GO THROUGH A
LINK TO YOUR PROCESS TO HAVE
THAT HAPPEN. AND IT'S MUCH LESS
EXPENSIVE AND MUCH LESS ONEROUS
FOR THEM TO GO THROUGH THE
PROCESS OF BECOMING A LEGAL
GUARDIAN- WHICH IS SHORTER LESS
EXPENSIVE AND SO THAT IS A LOT
OF THE REASON WHY THEY TEND TO
BECOME PART INCIDENT AND- HOLD
OFF ON. FORMALLY ADOPTED THE
CHILD. ALL I HAD OKAY THE
QUESTIONS COMMON. SEEING NONE
WAS REYES WHO MAKE CLOTHES. FOR
DIEGO AND FOR THE PARENTS WHO
RAISED HIM I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU WE DO
HAVE A MOTIONAND A SECOND THAT
MOTION IS DO PASS CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE. STONE BY STONE AYE
GALLAGHER. THE OLDER I SHOW. SO
I CHIU. GONZALEZ AND SALAS AYE
HOLDEN KALRA KALRA AYE KILEY
AYE AYE KILEY AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
OBERNOLTE RAY IS FIVE.
OBERNOLTE AYE REYES AYE. THE
BILL HAS. EIGHT VOTES GRIP THE
BILL IS OUT THANK YOU. SO OUR
NUMBER FIVE AB TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTY ONE MISTER MAY TIES NOT
WITH TIS I WILL BE PRESENTING
THAT LATER ON IT ON THE AGENDA
SO WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO ITEM
NUMBER SIX. AB THIRTY TWENTY.
OPERATOR IF YOU COULD OPEN THE
LINES FOR AB THIRTY TWENTY.
THEY GIVE A LINE FOR OPEN.
THANK YOU THIS GLORIA. GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN- THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT THAT
COMMITTEE WITH ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTY TWENTY TODAY MEMBERS
UNDER EXISTING LAW ONLY PUBLIC
PROSECUTORS MAY FILE LAWSUITS
CHARGING UNFAIR BUSINESS
PRACTICES THESE ACTIONS MAY BE
BROUGHT FORWARD BY THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY
FOR CITY ATTORNEY IN A CITY
WITH A POPULATION GREATER THAN
SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE. WHEN THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL OR DISTRICT
ATTORNEY BRINGS FOR AN ACTION
UNDER THE UNFAIR COMPETITION
ACT- DOT OFFICE RECEIVES ALL OF
THE CIVIL PENALTIES AWARDED BY
THE COURT HOWEVER WITH THE CITY
ATTORNEY BRING SUCH AN ACTION
THE CIVIL PENALTIES MUST BE
SPLIT EVENLY WITH THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY OF THAT COUNTY. THIS
DISCREPANCY HAS LEFT THOSE SAID
ELIGIBLE CITY ATTORNEY'S WITH A
DIFFICULT CHOICE OF BALANCING
THE PURSUIT OF LEGAL RECOURSE
AGAINST UNSCRUPULOUS ACTORS
WITH THE REALITY OF FIVE PUBLIC
RESOURCES AB THIRTY TWENTY
REQUIRES- PENALTIES BECAUSE
WHAT COLLECTED BY THE SAN DIEGO
CITY ATTORNEY FROM AN ACTION
UNDER THE UNFAIR COMPETITION
ACT TO BE PAID TO THE CITY OF
SAN DIEGO ENTIRELY. BY
ANSWERING AN EQUITABLE
DISTRIBUTION OF PENALTIES UNDER
THE UNFAIR COMPETITION ACT THIS
BILL WILL EMPOWER THE SAN DIEGO
CITY ATTORNEY TO PROSECUTE
AGAINST UNFAIR BUSINESSES IN
THE INTEREST OF CONSUMERS AND
OF OUR ENVIRONMENT THIS CHERRY
WITH ME THIS MORNING BY PHONE
IS SAN DIEGO CITY ATTORNEY MARK
ELLIOTT AND ALSO BY PHONE HERE
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AND
QUESTIONS COMMITTEE MEMBERS MAY
HAVE IS MARKET ACCOUNT OF THE
OFFICE OF THE ATTORNEY MARK
MARK IT. UP RESPECT THE. YOU
THAT YOU MISTER FOR THE WITNESS.
THANK YOU MISTER GLORIA HAVE
THE TWO MARK ANGKOR AND MAHER
EL LISTA AS- TO. BY PHONE ARE
YOU ON THE PLEASE. YEAH COULD
THAT THE BAND ERA CREATE MARK
ALLIA. AND I COMING THROUGH
OKAY YES WE CAN YOU GOOD
MORNING. PERFECT ALRIGHT THANK
YOU FROM THE MEMBER GLORIA. I
AM STANDING AT THE ATTORNEY
MARA ALLIOT THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO YOU
ABOUT THIS IMPORTANT BELL. AND
HE JUST HEARD UNDER STATE LAW.
ERNIE PAPER BUT CITY OF MORE
THAN SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND HAVE AUTHORITY TO
BRING ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS BASED
ON UNFAIR COMPETITION LAWS. ON
BEHALF OF THE PEOPLE OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WHEN
SHOOTING WHICH CASES TO PURSUE
I LOOK FOR EGREGIOUS CASES
WHERE OUR ENVIRONMENT AND BEING
HARMED CONSUMERS ARE BEING
DEFRAUDED BY BUSINESS. WORKERS
ARE BEING SHORT CHANGED BY AN
UNSCRUPULOUS EMPLOYER OR THE
HEALTH AND WELFARE OF OUR
PEOPLE IS JEOPARDIZED. WE
TYPICALLY GIVE THE BUSINESS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO COMPLY AND THEN
BRING LITIGATION WHEN OUR
EFFORTS TO EDUCATE AND GAIN
COMPLIANCE TRAIL. WE'VE BROUGHT
CASES THAT ALLOW US TO ENSURE
HARD WORKING SAN DIEGANS THEIR
PAYS WHAT THEY'RE LOOKING FOR
WORK THEY PERFORMED CONSUMERS
ARE NOT CHARGED HIDDEN FEES OR
OTHERWISE EXPLOITED. POLLUTANTS
ARE REMOVED FROM OUR WATER WAYS
AND THOSE WHO ARE ADDICTED TO
OPIOIDS CAN ACCESS THE THIRD
THAT THEY NEED TO RECOVER FROM
THEIR ADDICTION. EIGHT AND SURE.
AND ARE IMPORTANT TO THE PEOPLE
OF SAN DIEGO. UNDER EXISTING
LAW THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO NOT
SHARE THE CIVIL PENALTIES IT
RECOVERED FROM THESE CASES WITH
THE COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO. EVEN
IF THE COUNTY DOES NOT STAND
SINGLE SECOND THE FIFTEENTH
WITH THE CASE. IF HOWEVER THE
COUNTY BRINGS THE CASE UNDER
THE LONG AND RECOVERY PENALTIES
THE LAW DOES NOT REQUIRE THE
COUNTY TO SHARE THE PROCEEDS IT
RECOVERS WITH THE CITY. THE
DISTRIBUTION IS NOT FAIR AND IT
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE. WE'RE
COVERING THE PENALTIES FOR THE
WORK WE DO IS VERY IMPORTANT.
WE INVEST THE PENALTIES LEAVE
THE COVER INTO DOING MORE WORK
THAT PROTECTS CONSUMERS WORKERS
AND OUR ENVIRONMENT. IF
UNFORTUNATE WHEN WE MUST REJECT
THE CASE BECAUSE THE COCKPIT
PURSUING IT IS OUTWEIGHED BY
THE PANEL PEOPLE WHATEVER.
UNDER EIGHTY THIRTY TWENTY THE
CITY OF SAN DIEGO WOULD KEEP
ALL THE PENALTY THEY WERE
COVERED WHEN THE RECOVERY IS
DUE SOLELY TO ITS OWN EFFORT.
THIS ENABLES US TO CONTINUE THE
GOOD WORK THAT WE DO ON BEHALF
OF THE PEOPLE OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. I URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT AB THIRTY TWENTY. ALSO
ON THE LINE IS CHIEF DEPUTY
CITY ATTORNEY MARK AND CORN HE
OVERSEES ARE A PERMANENT CIVIL
ENFORCEMENT UNIT WHICH IS
PRIMARILY RESPONSIBLE FOR.
PROSECUTING SEVENTEEN TWO
HUNDRED CASES MARKET ALSO
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION. AGAIN THANK YOU FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY. THANK YOU. MR
ACCORDING TESTIMONY THAT YOU'D
LIKE TO GIVE FOR YOU JUST
AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS. NO
MISTER CHAIRMAN I'M AVAILABLE
FOR QUESTIONS THANK YOU OKAY.
THANK YOU. IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE HEARING ROOM WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY
TWENTY. SEEING NONE IS THERE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTY TWENTY. IF YOU'RE A
REPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THE TIME. AGAIN THE
PROMPTER ONE AND THEN ZERO IF
YOU'RE IN SUPPORT. THERE'S NO
ONE IN SUPPORT AT THE TIME.
THANK YOU IS THERE I HAVE NO
OPPOSITION LISTED IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE- ROOM WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB
THIRTY TWENTY. SEEING NONE IS
THERE ANYBODY ON THE PHONE WHO
WOULDLIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF THIRTY TWENTY. IF
YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE IF THEY'RE ALL AT
THIS TIME. BUT NO ONE IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU I'M GONNA
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS COMMENTS THIS
GALLAGHER. YEAH SO. I THINK THE
LARGEST CONCERN IS THAT THIS
MAY BE UNCONSTITUTIONAL- AS A
VIOLATE ARTICLE FOUR SECTION
SIXTEEN. WHICH REQUIRES THAT A
LOCAL OR SPECIAL STATUTE IS
pCAN BE MADE APPLICABLE- SO THE
QUESTION BECOMES- AND THE
REASON THAT'S IN THERE IS WHY
NOT DO IT GENERAL STATUTE THAT
SAYS ALL CITIES- COULD IN FACT
COLLECT. ALL THE PENALTIES- AND
NOT SHARE THEM WITH THE
COUNTIES WHY WE DO THIS ONLY
FOR ONE. JURISDICTION SO I
THINK THERE IS A- YOU'RE VERY
FUNDAMENTAL CONSTITUTIONAL
ISSUE THERE THAT WE WOULD BE
CONCERNED ABOUT. BUT MAYBE I
JUST GOT I MEAN AND I'M HEARING
I HEARD SOME OF THE TESTIMONY
OTHER THINGS BEING HIGHLIGHTED
AS- THINGS THAT THE CITY
ATTORNEY WOULD WANT TO GO AFTER
PROBABLY THINGS THAT EVERY CITY
AND CALIFORNIA PROBABLY DEALS
WITH IN SOME ASPECT AND YET
THEY ALSO HAVE THE SAME
PROVISION THAT THEY HAVE TO
SHARE- WITH THE COUNTIES. SO I
GUESS I'M TRYING TO SEE LIKE
WHAT IS. WHAT IS MAYBE SO
FUNDAMENTALLY GOING ON IN SAN
DIEGO THAT ISN'T PRESENT. IN
OTHER AREAS. AND THEN I'LL GO
TO THIS LIKE IS NOW THE BEST
TIME TO BE REALLY GOING AFTER A
LOT OF BUSINESSES- WHEN PEOPLE
ARE STRUGGLING CERTAINLY THERE
ARE. LEGITIMATE VIOLATIONS. BUT
YOU KNOW. THE OPPOSITE COULD BE
TRUE AS WELL THAT YOU KNOW
WE'RE GOING AFTER BUSINESSES AT
A TIME WHEN- A LOT OF PEOPLE
ARE STRUGGLING JUST TO SURVIVE-
ESPECIALLY IN THE YOU KNOW IN
OUR LARGE CITIES. HAPPY TRYING
FIELD- THINK THERE'S A COUPLE
QUESTIONS IN THERE WITH REGARD
TO THE FIRST MATTER THERE IS A
DECLARATION OF SPECIAL STATUTE
IN SECTION TWO OF THE BILL HAS
PROPOSED TO YOUR OBSERVATION
THAT THIS IS LIMITED TO THE
CITY OF SAN DIEGO- THE-
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS OR SYNOPSIS
POINTS OUT THE LAST YEAR IN A
VERY SIMILAR BILL WITH A
BROADER- HEATING EIGHTY COMPASS
MORE COMMUNITIES. HOWEVER THAT
BILL WAS VETOED BY GOVERNOR DO
SOME- YOU KNOW THIS IS
BASICALLY A FIVE TO THREE
CITIES- CITIES OF SAN DIEGO SAN
JOSE AND LOS ANGELES- BECAUSE
THAT BROADER BILL- WAS NOT
SIGNED INTO LAW WE'RE BACK HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
CITY A GO WITH THIS IS NOT
CONTROVERSIAL THERE'S NOT A
FIGHT BETWEEN THE COUNTY IN THE
STATE ASSEMBLY ASKING FOR THE-
YOUR LAST POINT YEAH. IRAQI
THERE DIDN'T TIMES FOR
BUSINESSES BUT THIS TOGETHER
I'M SURE- YOU ARE FAMILIAR WITH
THE FACT THAT THERE ARE MANY
BUSINESSES ARE STRUGGLING. BUT
THERE ARE ALSO MANY BUSINESSES
THAT ARE ENGAGING IN ILLEGAL
BEHAVIOR EXPORTING THE
PANDEMIC. AND WENT TO THE
EXTENT THAT WE CAN AUTHORIZE
THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO TO GO
AFTER THAT. THANK YOU RECOGNIZE
HOW YOUR COUNTY YOUR DA'S
OVERWHELMED BY WORK HI THIS
WOULD ALLOW. THE CITY ATTORNEY
TO ALSO GO AFTER THIS THING
WITHOUT HAVING TO- CONSIDER THE
FACT THAT THIS WOULD BE NEXT.
X. BUT- EXPENDING. A FINITE
PUBLIC RESOURCES- WITHOUT BEING
ABLE TO PROPERLY- REIMBURSE
THOSE EFFORTS INSTEAD HAVE A
SHARE THAT- THOSE PROCEEDS BUT
WITH THE COUNTY SAN DIEGO WHO.
AS OUR CITY ATTORNEY MENTION
MADE DONE NOTHING- WITH REGARD
TO LEGAL PROCEEDING BUT IT'S
STILL ENTITLED TO HALF. OF THE
WAR. MORE JUST. A QUICK
RESPONSE YOU KNOW. YES LAST
YEAR'S LEGISLATION WAS VETOED
BY THE GOVERNOR I'M CONCERNED
THIS ONE'S GONNA GET VETOED BY
THE CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT-
BECAUSE IT IS A SPECIAL STATUTE
WHERE YOU COULD DO A GENERAL. A
STATUTE OF GENERAL
APPLICABILITY. AND THEN LOOK
I'D THERE'S NOTHING THAT
PRECLUDES RIGHT NOW CITY
OFFICES IN CITY ATTORNEYS FROM
GOING AFTER ABOUT ACTORS AND
THEY CAN AND SHOULD DO THAT. IT
SEEMS TO ME THAT THIS IS GOING
TO GREATER INCENTIVIZE BECAUSE
NOW IT'S A REVENUE SOURCE IS
EVEN MORE OF A GRADE A REVENUE
SOURCE AND I'VE SEEN INSTANCES.
WHERE WHEN THAT'S THE CASE- I
WOULD ARGUE FRIVOLOUS SUITS GET
BROUGHT AGAINST SMALL
BUSINESSES BECAUSE HEY THEY
THEY'RE GONNA GET. YOU HAVE TO
SETTLE. OR RISK LOSING THEIR
ENTIRE BUSINESS AND SO. YOU
KNOW IT BECOMES A MONEY MAKER-
IN A WAY THAT I THINK IS NOT
VERY JUST YOU KNOW FOR THE
BUSINESSES AND FOR PEOPLE THAT
ARE JUST TRYING AGAIN AT THAT
ARE GOING TO SOME REALLY
DIFFICULT CIRCUMSTANCES RIGHT
NOW SO THAT WOULD BE MY
CONCERN. AND JUST TO MAKE SURE
IT'S ON THE RECORD MISTER
CHAIRMAN I HERE WITH MISTER
GALLAGHER ST I WOULD JUST POINT
OUT THAT- THERE ARE FEW THAT
JUST LET AGAINST THAT ARE GOING
TO BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE AT THE
BALLOT BOX IN THE CASE OF THE
CITY ATTORNEY- THIS INDIVIDUAL
MUST GO BEFORE THE VOTERS OF
SAN DIEGO EVERY FOUR YEARS. IF
THEY'RE IN THIS USING THIS
AUTHORITY I SUSPECT THE PUBLIC
HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE I THINK
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS TO
TAKE TO ALLOW THEM TO ACTUALLY
MAKE THE DECISION TO BE ABLE TO
PURSUE THIS WITH THEIR FINITE
RESOURCES. YOU'RE BOTH KNOW
WHAT WE'LL GET OUR BUDGET YOU
CAN IMAGINE WHAT THEY'RE HAVING
TO DO DOWN THERE AND THAT
SHOULD NOT BE AN EXCUSE TO OUT
BAD ACTORS TO BE HELD ON
ACCOUNTABLE. THIS AT LEAST IT
GIVES MORE OF A CHANCE THAT
SOME OF THESE FOLKS ARE
ENGAGING BAD BEHAVIOR HAS SOME
RISK OF BEING HELD ACCOUNTABLE
NOT NECESSARY CARP WANTED
RESOURCE THEY'RE STILL LIMITED.
BUT THEY WOULD NOT HAVE TO
SHARE THE PROCEEDS OF THIS
STUFF TO PICK ME A BURST OF
WORKED ON BEHALF OF THE PUBLIC
WITH AN AGENCY DID NOTHING TO
ACTUALLY EFFECTUATE THAT
POSITIVE OUTCOME. IF YOU MISSED.
I'M IS THERE MOTION KNOW
THERE'S AN ALL MAKE A MOTION I
WANT TO THANK YIELD MISS CORY
LIKE HEY WE HAVE A MOST IS
THEIR SECOND AND SECOND THANK
YOU I'D LIKE TO CO AUTHOR IF
POSSIBLE THIS BILL- JUST SO
PEOPLE ARE WHERE THE THIS ISN'T
A RANDOM DESIGNATION THE SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND IS IN
THE BNP CODE IT'S ALSO- AND THE
LABOR CODE WHICH ALLOWS. ADD
THESE LARGER CITIES INCLUDING
THE SAN FRANCISCO BUT THAT'S
DIFFERENT HAS ALSO THE COUNTY I
GUESS THEY DON'T HAVE THE SAME
I'M REVENUE ISSUE BUT IT WE
PROVIDE THE CITIES THE
OPPORTUNITY TO UTILIZE THE LOT
IN A DIFFERENT WAY THAT OTHER
CITY ATTORNEY STOPPED- THEY
CAN'T BRING THESE ACTIONS AND
SO IT SEEMS FAIR THAT WHEN
THEY- PUT CONSIDERABLE
RESOURCES. IN MOST THESE
ACTIONS ARE AGAINST BIG
CORPORATIONS AND THEY HAVE TO
USE CONSIDERABLE RESOURCES IN
ORDER TO EVEN LITIGATE IT THAT
WHEN THEY WHEN THEY SHOULD GET
THE FRUITS OF THAT LABOR ON
BACK SO I ABSOLUTELY-
APPRECIATED AND APPRECIATE THE
WORK THAT THE SAN DIEGO CITY
ATTORNEY HAS DONE AND THAT ENDS
UP BEING AND WHEN HE WON'T
THESE SORT OF FOR SOME ACTION
SAM THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION COMMENTS. ALRIGHT
THIS IS LAURIE I'D I THINK IT'S
A IT'S A FIVE BILL AND I FOR
ONE DO NOT SEE A CUTS TO PROP.
THIS IS. AT A GROUP THAT.
COUNTY SAN DIEGO LEASE. DON'T
HAVE A QUALM ABOUT MOVING THIS
FORWARD AND ABSOLUTELY SUPPORT
YOUR- YOUR BILL SO WITH THAT
YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU SIR I
JUST WANT EXPRESS MY
APPRECIATION TO SERIOUSLY
TURNING OUR ELLIOT CAR
PARTNERSHIP IN THIS LEGISLATION
THANK- MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
DIEGO FOR HER KIND WORDS AND
HAPPY TO ADD YOU AND I JUST FOR
THE RECORD WOULD POINT OUT THAT
AND I SHOULD HAVE. SAID THIS AN
ANSWERING MISTER GALLAGHER THE
PROCEEDS THAT WOULD COME FROM
JUSTIFICATION MUST BE SPENT BY
THE CITY ATTORNEY ON
ADDITIONAL- THE BUSINESS
PRACTICE UNFAIR BUSINESS
PRACTICES FOR SMITH SO THIS IS
NOT INTENDED TO BE- A
SWEEPSTAKES- FOR THE CITY
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE ASSEMBLY
MEANT TO HELP HER DEVELOP HER
AND SUCCESSORS DO THEIR JOB- AS
EFFECTIVELY AS POSSIBLE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR IDOL
TODAY. THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND THE MOST
ASTUTE CALL THE ROLL PLEASE
STONE BY. STONE I GALLAGHER. GO
NO CHAO. CHAO I TO. FROM
DOLLARS. CONSOLES I HOLDEN. ALL
KALRA I KILEY. I'M SORRY WAS
THAT NO KILEY NO. MAIENSCHEIN
OBERNOLTE. OBERNOLTE NO REYES
REYES AYE. THAT HAS FIVE VOTE
CHECK THE BILL HAS FIVE ALSO
PUT ON CALL TECHNICIAN THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT MISS AGUIAR-CURRY.
THIS TAKES US TO ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN AB THIRTY ONE THIRTY
THREE OPERATOR IF YOU COULD
OPEN THE LINES FOR A. B. THIRTY
ONE THIRTY THREE. AND OPEN
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING
CHAIRMAN STONE AND REMEMBERS-
AB THIRTY ONE THIRTY THREE
CODIFIES CALIFORNIA'S
COMMITMENT TO RESETTLING
REFUGEES WITHOUT DISCRIMINATION
AS PART OF THE UNITED STATES
RECEPTION AND PLACEMENT PROGRAM
REFUGEES ARE MEN WOMEN AND
CHILDREN WHO ARE FORCED TO FLEE
THEIR COUNTRY OF ORIGIN TO SEEK
ANOTHER COUNTRY DUE TO WAR.
GOVERNMENTAL OF PEOPLE OR
PERSECUTION BASED UPON THE
RELIGION NATIONALITY OR
MEMBERSHIP IN A PARTICULAR
SOCIAL OR POLITICAL GROUP.
CALIFORNIA HAS HAD A LONG LONG
TRADITION OF OFFERING REFUGEES
ARE HAVING RECEIVED NEWLY
ARRIVED REFUGEES SINCE NINETEEN
EIGHTY. THESE REFUGEES THEN
TURN AROUND A CONTRIBUTE
SIGNIFICANT ECONOMIC AND
CULTURAL CONTRIBUTIONS TO OUR
STATE INCLUDING SEVENTEEN
BILLION IN SPENDING POWER AND
THE DIVERSITY WE ARE SO PROUD
OF. WITH FEDERAL FUNDING
SUPPORT RESETTLEMENT AGENCIES
PROVIDE DIRECT SUPPORT TO NEWLY
ARRIVED REFUGEES PLUS
ASSISTANCE TO ASYLUM SEEKERS.
DOCTOR RECEPTIVE RECIPIENTS AND
UNDOCUMENTED PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA. THIS BILL SIMPLY
CODIFIES IN A LOCKED IN OUR LAW
THAT WE WILL CONTINUE TO UPHOLD
OUR COMMITMENT TO ASSISTING
THOSE SEEKING REFUGEE IN OUR
COUNTRY AND STATE. I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE AND I HAVE A
SPEAKER KAREN FERGUSON FROM THE
INTERNATIONAL RESCUE COMMITTEE
TO SUPPORT ME ON THE PHONE.
THANK YOU I DO HAVE ONE SUPPORT
WITNESS LISTED AND THAT IS DR
FERGUSON DUTCH FERGUSON ARE YOU
WITH US. I AM YES GREAT WE CAN
HEAR YOU PLEASE GO AHEAD YOU
CAN HEAR ME OKAY GREAT ALREADY
SO THIS IS KAREN FERGUSON I'M
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
INTERNATIONAL RESCUE COMMITTEE
IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA THE I RC
THE IDEA OF THE REFUGEE
RESETTLEMENT AGENCY WITH TWENTY
FIVE OFFICES SPREAD ACROSS
FIFTEEN STATES IN THE U. S. AND
HERE IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE
SEVEN WEEKS SETTLEMENT SITE. WE
ARE ONE OF THE NINE WITH
SETTLEMENT AGENCIES THAT THE
THING REFUGEES. YOUR IDEA OF
HOME CAL. THIRD ALONG SIDE YOU
MILLER. ENACT FOR OUR REFUGEES
REUNITING WITH FAMILY AFTER
CLEAN WAR AND COMPLEX. I'M
PARTICIPATING TODAY TO
REPRESENT I A SEAT THE PART FOR
AB THREE ONE THREE THREE
REFUGEES FROM THIRD BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY AND
MY AT. WHAT DID YOU RETIREMENT
IS A PROCESS THAT IS DESIGNED
AS A PUBLIC PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP
BUILT UP OVER THE LAST FORTY
YEARS AND INCORPORATING FEDERAL
AND STATE GOVERNMENT COMMUNITY
PARTNERS AND RETIREMENT AGENCY
INPUT. TO FACILITATE A
SUCCESSFUL TRANSITION FOR CLIMB.
I'D RETIREMENT AGENCIES WE WORK
CLOSELY WITH A WIDE RANGE OF
LOCAL AGENCIES AND WE PROVIDE
FEDERALLY FUNDED SUPPORT TO
HELP NEWLY ARRIVED REFUGEES AND
OTHER VIOLENT VULNERABLE
GROUPS. SUCH AS VICTIMS OF
TRAFFICKING INTEGRATE AND
THRIVE IN THE COMMUNITY. THIS
WORK BENEFITS THE REFUGEES AND
THE COMMUNITIES THAT ARE THEIR
NEW HOME. DESPITE ALL OF THIS
COORDINATION THE RELATIONSHIP
THAT MANIFEST IN A BIG CIRCLE
WITH THE ELEMENT PROGRAM CAN BE
ELIMINATED IN AN ACTION AS WITH
AS AN EXECUTIVE ORDER. IN THE
LAST THREE YEARS DIRECTED YOU
WOULD SETTLEMENT INFRASTRUCTURE
HASFACED UNPRECEDENTED ATTACK
AGAINST WHAT WAS ONCE THE
SYSTEMS THAT ENJOYED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT. IN THE FEW YEARS WE
HAVE WITNESSED STATE OPT TO
WITHDRAW FROM THE RESETTLEMENT
PROGRAM AND IN A MINUTE AND AN
ADMINISTRATION THAT JEFF THIS
PAST WINTER REQUIRED GOVERNORS
AND LOCAL COUNTY AND CITY BOARD
TO PUBLICLY CERTIFIED THEIR
CONSENT IF THEY WISHED FIFTY
RETIREMENT CONTINUE IN OUR
STATE AS ASSEMBLYMEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY JUST MENTIONED
CALIFORNIA HAS ALWAYS BEEN A
WELCOMING HOME TO THE WORLD'S.
MOST AT RISK. IT IS THE STATE
WHERE THE RETIREMENT PROGRAM AS
WE KNOW IT TODAY WAS BORN WHEN
THE FIRST WAVE OF SOUTHEAST
ASIAN REFUGEES ARRIVED QUICKLY
BECAME SAFETY AND SHELTER. I
THINK IT'S A MAJOR MARK ON
CALIFORNIA CONTRIBUTING MAJOR
INDUSTRY STARTING A BUSINESS IS
BOTH SMALL AND LARGE AND
REVITALIZED TO COMMUNICATE
COMMUNITIES AS THEY BUY HOMES
AND RAISE THEIR FAMILIES HERE.
IN FACT IN THIS LATEST PANDEMIC
REFUGEES WITH HEALTHCARE
TRAINING ARE STEPPING UP TO
HELP ON THE FRONTLINE. OUR
STATE AND LOCAL COMMUNITY
BENEFIT FROM THEIR REBELLION.
WE ASK YOU TO PASS AB THREE ONE
THREE THREE AND PROTECT THE
INFRASTRUCTURE OF THE U. S.
RESETTLEMENT PROGRAM HERE IN
CALIFORNIA FOR FUTURE REFUGEES
THAT WILL ARISE AND CALL THE
STATE HOME. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
I DON'T HAVE ANY WELL AS LISTED
IS THERE ANYONE IN THE HEARING
ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE TO USE
BEACON SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY ONE
THIRTY THREE. SEEING NONE IS
THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF AB THIRTY ONE THIRTY THREE.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR AB THREE ONE THREE
THREE. PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO. ONCE AGAIN TO SHOW
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE DIDN'T
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND LOCAL
THE LINE NUMBER FIFTY LINE FIVE
ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. WE DO HAVE
ONE MORE TO BE JUST A MOMENT TO
GET THEIR LINE NUMBER PLEASE.
I'D LIKE TO GO TO MY NUMBER
TWELVE LINE NUMBER TWELVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YES GOOD MORNING
THIS IS THAT. THANK YOU. WHAT
THE INITIAL SUPPORT FOR A BI
THREE ONE THREE THREE CLASS
PLEASE PRESS ONE TO ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WE HAVE NO ONE ALSO
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU OPERATOR
I. HAVE NO ONE LISTED IN
OPPOSITION IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE HEARING ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB
THIRTY ONE THIRTY THREE. SEEING
NONE IS THERE ANYONE ON THE
PHONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF AB THIRTY ONE
THIRTY THREE. HELLO MANISHA
OPPOSITION FOR EIGHTY THREE ONE
THIRTY THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
TO ZERO AT THIS TIME. NO ONE IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE CONTINUE SIR
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU OPERATOR.
WILL BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS COMMENTS. SECOND TO
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
THANK YOU ALRIGHT MS
AGUIAR-CURRY MAY CLOSE- I JUST
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME AND
YOUR WORKING WITH US ON THIS.
BILLTHANK YOU WE DO HAVE THE
MOST IN A SECOND THAT MOTION IS
DO PASCHAL ROLE PLEASE. STONE
BY STONE HI GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER AYE CHAU. CHOW I. TO
GONZALEZ. CONTROLS AYE HOLDEN
KALRA OUR AYE KILEY KILEY AYE
THANK YOU MAIENSCHEIN OBERNOLTE
OBERNOLTE AYE RIAS. RIOS I.
THAT HAS EIGHT VOTE EIGHT BOOKS
OF BILLS THAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH CHAIRMAN MEMBERS. RIGHT
THAT BRINGS US TO THE NUMBER
EIGHT AB THIRTY TO FIFTY FORM
IS THE MOST. OPERATOR PLEASE
OPEN THE LINES FOR AB THIRTY TO
FIFTY FOUR. WHEN THEY'RE OPEN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AB THIRTY TO FIFTY FOUR
SIX TO CLARIFY CURRENT
CALIFORNIA LAW. WHEN A CONTRACT
IS NEGOTIATED AND WON A FIVE
LANGUAGE OTHER THAN ENGLISH A
PHYSICAL CONTRACT MUST BE
PROVIDED IN THAT LANGUAGE BUT
THIS PROVISION DOES NOT APPLY
TO MONOLINGUAL CLOSE SIGNERS
THIS BILL WOULD ENSURE CO
SIGNERS HAVE THE SAME
PROTECTIONS. FOR EXAMPLE WHEN A
SPANISH SPEAKING COSIGNER SIGNS
IN ENGLISH CONTRACT THERE HELL
TO THE TERMS OF THE ENGLISH
CONTRACT WITHOUT THESE
PROTECTIONS CO SIGNERS ARE
EXTREMELY SUSCEPTIBLE TO FRAUD
BECAUSE THEY MAY NOT UNDERSTAND
THE TERMS OF THE CONTRACT AND
ARE TAKING ON ALL THE RISK IN
ALONE WITHOUT RECEIVING. ANY OF
THE BENEFITS IF A CO SIGNER
SPEAKS TO ONE OF FIVE LANGUAGES
OTHER THAN ENGLISH THEY WOULD
NEED TO RECEIVE AN IN LANGUAGE
CONTRACT UNLESS THEY PROVIDE
THEIR OWN TRANSLATOR LIKE A
FAMILY MEMBER. DUE TO THE
CENSUS NEARLY 45% OF CALIFORNIA
HOUSEHOLDS. SPEAK A LANGUAGE
OTHER THAN ENGLISH. THIS BILL
IS ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT IN
LIGHT OF THE I'M PRESIDENT.
UNPRECEDENTED RISE IN
UNEMPLOYMENT THROUGHOUT THE
STATE AND COUNTRY. IT IS
FORESEEABLE THAT MANY PEOPLE
TURN TO PERSONAL LOANS AND
CREDIT CARDS WHICH MAY REQUIRE
CO SIGNERS TO ADDRESS THE
RISING DEBT AND PAY FOR BASIC
NEEDS- TODAY ON THE PHONE TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL IS DANNY
CONDO KAISER REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME CONSUMER
COALITION. AND DOES RAINY AND-
FROM. THE JUSTICE AND DIVERSITY
CENTER OF THE BAR ASSOCIATION
OF SAN FRANCISCO. THANK YOU I
DO HAVE TO SUPPORT WITNESSES
THIS KIND OF KAISER AND MS
MILLION NORTH. ARE YOU ON THE
LINE PLEASE. YES YES OKAY- THIS
KIND OF CLOSER THE- GOOD GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS
JENNY CANDOR CARTER ON BEHALF
OF THE SPONSORS OF THE STILL
THE CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME
CONSUMER COALITION CLICK OF THE
STATEWIDE COALITION OF FOURTEEN
LEGALLY PROVIDERS THAT SIR
STRIVE TO ENSURE THE ALL
CONSUMERS IN CALIFORNIA HOW
THEIR VOICES HEARD BY THE
LEGISLATURE WE PART OF FAMILY
MEMBER WOMEN'S AUTHORSHIP OF AB
THIRTY TO FIFTY FOUR WHICH WILL
PROVIDE SIGNIFICANT ANTI FRAUD
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS BY
REQUIRING THAT NON ENGLISH
SPEAKING CO SIGNERS WHO DO NOT
HAVE A DISINTEREST. INTERPRETER
BE GIVEN A COPY OF THEIR
CONTRACT IN THE LANGUAGE THEY
SPEAK. CODE SIGNING OF OFTEN
LOOK WHEN THE PRIMARY BORROWERS
CREDIT IS POOR OR UNDER
ESTABLISHED. THE BORROWER IS
INCENTIVIZE YOU BRING ON A CO
SIGNER IN ORDER TO OBTAIN WHAT
HE NEEDS OR WANTS. THE VERY
NATURE OF CODE FINDING IS A
RELATIONSHIP WHERE IN THE
COSIGNER HAVE BETTER CREDIT
THAN THE BORROWER. A TAKE ON
EQUAL RISK FOR ANOTHER THE
BENEFITS AND THEY WILL SUFFER
GREATER HARM TO THEIR CREDIT IN
THE EVENT OF DEFAULT. DAMAGE TO
ONE CREDIT MAY RESULT IN
DIFFICULTY IN FINDING HOUSING
AND SAFE NEIGHBORHOODS
ATTAINING GOOD PAYING JOBS. AND
HIGHER INTEREST RATE COMPUTER
LUNCH OR FINANCING. THE
COSIGNER MUST CARRY THE
FINANCIAL BURDEN IF THE
BORROWER DROPS OR SUFFERS THE
CONSEQUENCES IF SHE CANNOT
AFFORD IT. WITH MANY
CALIFORNIANS LIVING PAYCHECK TO
PAYCHECK THE LATTER SCENARIO IS
OFTEN THE CASE. THIS BILL WOULD
PROVIDE FOR A MUCH NEEDED YET
MODEST EXPANSION OF EXISTING
LAW CIVIL CODE SIXTEEN THIRTY
TWO WHICH WAS ENACTED IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX TO
INCREASE PROTECTIONS FOR NON
ENGLISH SPEAKING CONSUMERS.
UNDER AB THIRTY TO FIFTY FOUR
AT THE COSIGNER SPEAKS ONE OF
THE FIVE INDICATED LANGUAGES
THEY WILL BE GIVEN A CONTRACT
IN THAT LANGUAGE UNLESS THEY
SUPPLY THEIR OWN DISINTERESTED
INTERPRETER. LEAVE PROTECTIONS
ARE INTEGRAL TO PROTECTING NON
ENGLISH SPEAKERS FROM FRAUD
MISREPRESENTATION AND LASTING
HARM TO THEIR CREDIT. IN OUR
NEW ECONOMIC CLIMB AND WE FOR
SEE MORE PEOPLE TAKING UP
PERSONAL LOANS AND LINES OF
CREDIT. AND WE FEEL THAT THE
PROTECTIONS INCLUDING IN THE
INCLUDED IN THIS BILL ARE MORE
IMPORTANT THAN EVER WE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION. AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
THAT. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. NUMBER THAT THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS DESIREE
ONE OF THE INTEGRITY CENTER OF
THE PARTICIPATION OF CAMPING
DISCOUNTS ARE THE PROVIDER
DIRECTLY WILL SERVICE HELLO
INCOMPLETE CAMERAS I'VE
EXPERIENCED YOU MOMENT WORSE
THAN TELLING A CLIENT I'M SORRY
I CAN'T HELP YOU BECAUSE YOU
CAN'T SPEAK ENGLISH BUT A LOT
OF NOT YOU NEED FOR PROTECTION
ALL RIGHT THE DOES. THAT
SOMEONE WHO CAN. MY CLIENT
LOCAL. AND ACTUALLY MODELING
OKAY. OKAY LIKE. BUT THE CAR
DEALERSHIP IN NOT HURT YOU NEED
MY PAPER. THE EMPLOYER HIS WIFE
AND DEALERSHIP REPRESENT A
DISCUSS TURNED AND HIGHER LEE
ENGLISH. WHAT YOU AFTER WHERE
SHE WOULD HAVE TO PAY A THE
CARD. THEY NO. AND IN ADDITION
A HOLDER SIX MONTHS CONTRACT
THE CONTRACT ENTIRELY TO THAT.
WHERE THE LARGEST ETHNIC AND
ALRIGHT. THE CLASS CLOUT CALL
MEDICAL THIRTY. AND THAT WAS
HOW SHE FIRST LEARNED THAT YOU
THE TOP OF THE CAR. ONE ECOTEX
ARE EQUALLY FINANCIALLY
RESPONSIBLE FOR DEBT ON WHICH
THEY CO SIGN. ALONG THE
QUESTION WILL BE LEGALLY BOUND
TO CONTRACT THE OPPORTUNITY
OPPORTUNITY TO READ AND
UNDERSTAND THE TERMS ASSEMBLY
AND THE FACT THAT HE- THIS IS A
BIPARTISAN ISSUE A BASIC
CONTRACT REQUIREMENTS. IT IS IN
THE BEST INTEREST OF BOTH
CONSUMERS AND BUSINESSES THAT
ALL PARTIES WILL BE RESPONSIBLE
UNDER THE CONTACT. UNDERSTAND
WHAT YOU'VE GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY TO UNDERSTAND THE
TERMS UNDER WHICH THEY WILL BE
BALANCED. I JUST DON'T HAVE OT
CHANGED THE CATEGORY THE
BUSINESSES THAT ARE OBLIGATED
TO FIND AND WHEN THAT CONTRACT
THERE'S VERY LITTLE BURDEN FOR
THE DEFENSE WOEFULLY MONOLOGUE
BUT NOT AT THE GREAT BENEFIT OF
UNDERSTANDING I LEGAL AND
FINANCIAL OBLIGATIONS AS LONG.
THE BENEFITS THAT ALL QUITE BUT
I'M CONTACT ACTUALLY THANKED
THE TURN. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. EXACTLY DRIED UP.
THANK YOU. RIGHT IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF AB THIRTY TO FIFTY FOUR.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANYONE ON
THE TELEPHONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY
TO FIFTY FOUR. THE GENTLEMAN ON
THE PHONE LINE TO SHOW SUPPORT
OF AB THIRTY TO FIFTY FOUR
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND LOCAL TO LINE
NUMBER FORTY NINE NINE FORTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SOME OF
THE TERM MEMBERS CATALINA
SANCHEZ THE CARBON IN KINDER ON
BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL CONSUMER
LAW CENTER IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THE BOTTOM LINE NUMBER
FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
CHAIRMAN DON AND NUMBER THE
RETIRING UP THE PUBLIC
LAWCENTER IN ORANGE COUNTY AND
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT AT
EIGHTY THIRTY TO FIFTY FOUR.
THANK YOU. TEXACO TO LINE
NUMBER FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THE FIVE YEAR LINE NUMBER
TO OPEN. HELLO CHAIRMAN DOWN
THE NUMBER MY NAME AT THE END
OF THE CALDWELL AND I LOCAL
ROUTE THAT THE TRIP. WE SEEM TO
GET THE CAR THAT I MET BUT
ROUTE THE VENTURE THE GAL WE'RE
IN JUNK THE PORT EIGHTY THREE
TWO FIVE FOUR. THANK YOU. THE
REMINDER TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR
THREE TO FIVE FOUR PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE ONE SUPPORT.
THANK YOU I DO NOT HAVE ANY
LISTED OPPOSITION THIRTY ONE
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
AB THIRTY TO FIFTY FOUR. SEEING
NONE IS THERE ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINES WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK. IN OPPOSITION TO AB
THIRTY TO FIFTY FOUR. GENTLEMAN
ON THE PHONE LINE TO SHOW
OPPOSITION TO THIRTY TO FIFTY
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. O ONE IN
OPPOSITION SIR PLEASE CONTINUE
ALRIGHT THANK YOU OPERATOR FOR
YOU BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS COME AT. RIGHT SIGNAL
IS THE MORNING MAY CLOSED I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I HAVE
A- THANK YOU LOOKING FOR A
MOTION ON AB THIRTY. THANK YOU
pSECOND THAT MOTION IS TO PASS
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE. STONE BY
STONE AYE GALLAGHER GALLAGHER I
CHAO SO ALL RIGHT TO GONZALEZ
HI CONSOLES I HOLDEN KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY KILEY AYE
MAIENSCHEIN. OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE AYE RAY IS REYES AYE.
THAT HAS EIGHT VOTE THANK YOU
THE BILL IS OUT THANK YOU. IT
WAS KILEY. THANKS AS TO ITEM
NUMBER NINE AB THIRTY TWO
SEVENTY ONE OPERATOR WOULD YOU
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES FOR AB
THIRTY TWO SEVENTY ONE.
CAROLINE OPEN. MORNING ARE
STILL MORE TIMES THE MORNING
TOMORROW IF ALL RIGHT IS LEFT.
AB THIRTY TWO SEVENTY ONE
INSURERS THAT A VICTIM OF
CHILDHOOD SEXUAL ASSAULT CAN
PURSUE A CIVIL ACTION AGAINST
THE PERPETRATOR AND OTHER
RELEVANT PARTIES. THE BILL
WOULD GIVE A MINOR THE ABILITY
TO OPT OUT OR JUST A FORM OF
THE PROVISION IN IN A ROMAN
AGREEMENT FOR THEIR SCHOOL THE
DENIES THEM ANY LEGAL RIGHT
REMEDY FOR- PROCEEDING OR
PROCEDURE FOR A SPECIFIC TYPE
OF CLAIM ONE ARISING OUT OF A
CRIMINAL SEXUAL ASSAULT OR
BATTERY. IN OUR CIVIL JUSTICE
SYSTEM. COURTS ARE THE DEFAULT
FORUM FOR EDUCATING LEGAL
CLAIMS. YET PARTIES CAN OFFICE
TO CHANGE THAT TO FALL AND MANY
DO. WHEN ENTERING A CONTRACTOR
THE AGREED TO RESOLVE ANY
DISPUTES THAT MAY ARISE IN THE
COURSE OF THEIR CONTRACTUAL
RELATIONSHIP. THROUGH AN
ALTERNATIVE FORUM SUCH AS
ARBITRATION. ARBITRATION OFFERS
A NUMBER OF ADVANTAGES OVER
LITIGATION INCLUDING COSTS
SPEED ND PRIVACY. THAT'S WHY
IT'S FAVORED UNDER BOTH FEDERAL
AND STATE LAW. WE GENERALLY
RESPECT THE RIGHT OF
CONTRACTING PARTIES TO INCLUDE
AN ARBITRATION CLAUSE IN THEIR
AGREEMENT WHICH BINDS THEM TO A
CHANGE IN THE DEFAULT FORUM FOR
RESOLVING CLAIMS IN ADVANCE OF
ANY DISPUTE. BUT THIS PRINCIPLE
IS POORLY ADAPTED TO THE NARROW
AND UNIQUE CIRCUMSTANCE
PRESENTED HERE. WHERE THE AGENT
OF AN EDUCATION ESTABLISHMENT
HAS COMMITTED A HEINOUS ACT OF
SEXUAL VIOLENCE AGAINST A MINOR
ENTRUSTED TO ITS CARE. AS AN
INITIAL MATTER SCHOOLING IS
COMPULSORY FOR A MINOR THERE
MAY BE A CHOICE OF WHICH SCHOOL
TO ATTEND BUT THERE'S NO CHOICE
WHETHER TO ATTEND SCHOOL ALL
TOGETHER. SECOND IF THE SCHOOL
SELECTED REQUIRES AN ORAL
AGREEMENT THE MINOR DOES NOT
SIGN ANY CONTRACT HIM OR
HERSELF BUT IS BOUND BY THE
SIGNATURE OF THE PARENT. THIRD
A CRIMINAL SEXUAL ASSAULT IS
NOT AMONG THE REASONABLY
FORESEEABLE RISKS OF
ENROLLMENT. TERMS AND
CONDITIONS LIKE SCHOOL HOURS
TUITION DRESS CODES GRADING
STANDARDS REQUIREMENTS LIKE
TUITION ATTENDANCE THESE OF THE
SUBSTANCE OF THE AGREEMENT. THE
ONE COULD REASONABLY ANTICIPATE
AS THE BASIS FOR ANY DISPUTE.
MIDDLE SEXUAL ASSAULT IS AN
INJURY OF AN ALTOGETHER
DIFFERENT KIND THAT WOULD NOT
BE UNDERSTOOD AS SUBJECT TO
ARBITRATION BY A REASONABLE
PARENT MUCH LESS BY A MINOR
STUDENT WHO LIKELY WAS NOT
AWARE OF THE CAUSE OR THE
CONCEPT OF ARBITRATION AT ALL.
IT IS TRUE THAT THE FEDERAL
ARBITRATION ACT HAS A BROADLY
PREEMPTIVE THE FACT. ON STATE
LAWS LIMITING ARBITRATION. BUT
THE CIRCUMSTANCES UNDER WHICH A
MINOR CAN DECIPHER MY CONTRACT
THAT'S A DISTINCT QUESTION OF
STATE LAW AND NOT GOVERNED BY
THE FAA ITSELF. CALIFORNIA LAW
IN FACT ALREADY ALLOWS JUST
AFFIRMING CONTRACTS AND SEVERAL
CONTACTS. WELL IT'S POSSIBLE
THAT A COURT WOULDFIND NEVER
THE LESS THAT AB EIGHT THREE
TWO SEVEN ONE IMPERMISSIBLY
FAVORS ARBITRATION THIS FAVORS
ARBITRATION IN A WAYTHAT
TRIGGERS FAA PREVENT PREEMPTION
I AM. NOT AWARE OF ANY EXISTING
PRECEDENT TO THAT EFFECT AND I
BELIEVE THE ARGUMENT FOR A
CONTRARY HOLDING IS COMPELLING
GIVEN THE BILL'S NARROW SCOPE
AND THE UNIQUE CIRCUMSTANCES IT
ADDRESSES NAMELY- THE BILL
CREATES A RIGHTS INTO JUST A
FIRM. THAT IS NOT TARGETED AT
ARBITRATION AS SUCH BUT IS
LIMITED TO THAT PORTION OF AN
ENROLLMENT AGREEMENT- WHERE
JUST AFFIRMING- THE CONTRACT
IS- WORKABLE AND REASONABLE IN
OTHER WORDS- WE I WOULDN'T BE
REASONABLE TO HAVE A STUDENT BE
ABLE TO SIMPLY- DISA FIRM THEIR
ENROLLMENT AGREEMENT AT ANY
POINT BECAUSE THEY COULD JUST
YOU COULD JUMP BUT DROPPED OUT
OF SCHOOL WHATEVER THEY WANTED-
BUT IN THE- I HIGHLY UNUSUAL
AND HIGHLY. INJURIOUS
CIRCUMSTANCES PRESENTED BY THIS
BILL IT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE FOR
THEM TO BE ABLE TO DECIPHER THE
PART OF THE CONTRACT THAT IS
DIRECTLY RELATED TO BE DRESSING
THAT INJURY- SO- WITH THAT SAID
I RESPECT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE AND I HAVE TWO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT WHO ARE ON
THE LINE. THANK YOU I DO HAVE
TWO WITNESSES RICHARDS WORDS
AND STEPHEN SCHWARTZ. ONLINE
ARE YOU WITH US. YES MISTER
CHAIRMAN THIS IS RICHARD
SCHWARTZ. FOR I'M HERE- I
REBEKAH SCHWARTZ SEEKING UP OR-
EVEN SHORT OKAY- MISTER RICHARD
SCHWARTZ FIRST PLEASE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBERS KILEY
IN PARTICULAR MY NAME IS
RICHARD SCHWARTZ A PARTNER AT
THE LAW FIRM BROWN GEORGE ROCK
L. L. P. AND I HEARD YOU ALL
CANNELLA AYE ON A. B. THIRTY
TWO SEVENTY ONE. AB THIRTY TWO
SEVENTY ONE WOULD ALLOW
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE THE VICTIMS
AND CRIMINAL SEXUAL ASSAULT OR
SEXUAL BATTERY IN A SCHOOL
CONTACT EACH OTHER THROUGH THE
COURT SYSTEM EVEN IF THE SCHOOL
ENROLLMENT AGREEMENT WOULD
OTHERWISE SEND THAT STUDENT
ARBITRATION. RIGHT NOW
CALIFORNIA LAW AUTHORIZES
SCHOOL TOOK FOR STUDENTS AND
PARENTS TO SIGN. NON NEGOTIABLE
ENROLLMENT AGREEMENT. STOP AND
HAVE. THAT AMONG OTHER THINGS
ALLOW THOSE TO HIDE IT. BEHIND
THE VEIL CONFIDENTIAL. EVEN
WHEN A STUDENT HAS CLAIMS BASED
ON PROVEN CRIMINAL SEXUAL
MISCONDUCT. THE SECRECY THAT
SCHOOLS CAN REQUIRE THROUGH
FORCED ARBITRATION IS THAT
SPECIALLY PROBLEMATIC FOR
SCHOOL COMMUNITY. WHO
DESPERATELY NEED INFORMATION
ABOUT WHAT PROCEDURES THEIR
SCHOOLS ARE TAKING FOR FAILING
TO TAKE TO PREVENT CRIMINAL
SEXUAL MISCONDUCT ON THEIR
PREMISES. EVEN MORE PROBLEMATIC
IS THE IMPACT OF ARBITRATION ON
A VICTIM OF CRIMINAL SEXUAL
ASSAULT. CALIFORNIA LAW MAKES
IT CLEAR THAT AN ARBITRATOR CAN
DECIDE A MATTER BEFORE THEM NOT
ON THE BASIS OF THE RULE OF LAW
OR THE RULES OF EVIDENCE.
RATHER SOLELY ON AMBIGUOUS
NOTIONS OF EQUITY AS PERCEIVED
BY THAT ARBITRATOR OFTEN A
SINGLE PERSON WITH HIS OR HER
OWN BIASES AND PRECONCEPTIONS.
THAT MEANS THAT AN ARBITRATOR
CAN BLATANTLY IGNORE THE LAW
AND PREVENT IT STUDENT WHO IS
SEXUALLY ASSAULTED FROM
OBTAINING THE JUSTICE THEY
COULD OBTAIN THROUGH THE
COURTS. AB THIRTY TWO SEVENTY
ONE WOULD FIX THAT PROBLEM BY
ALLOWING STUDENTS TO DEATH THE
FIRM THOSE ENROLLMENT AGREEMENT
AFTER BEING THE VICTIM OF A
SEXUAL ASSAULT. I SHOULD
EMPHASIZE THAT AB THIRTY TWO
SEVENTY ONE HAS A VERY NARROW
SCOPE AND PROVISIONS ARE ONLY
TRIGGERED WHEN THERE IS
CRIMINAL SEXUAL MISCONDUCT THAT
FORM THE BASIS OF DISPUTED
CLAIM. CALIFORNIA CONVICTED
WILL ALL THAT ALLOW SCHOOLS TO
ESCAPE THE COURT SYSTEM AND
AVOID THE PUBLIC RECONCILIATION
PROCESS THAT THESE COMMUNITIES
NEED TO HEAL AND MOVE ON. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION AND THE IMPORTANT
BILL WHICH WOULD GO A LONG WAY
TO SECURING JUSTICE FOR THE
VICTIMS OF CRIMINAL OF
CHILDHOOD SEXUAL ASSAULT. I ASK
YOU TO THE MEMBERS ABOUT AYE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE. THANK YOU THE WITNESS
PLEASE. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK BEFORE YOU
TODAY FOR HEARING THE VICTIM'S
PERSPECTIVE ON A SUBJECT
IMPORTANT TO PUBLIC SAFETY IT
IS AN HONOR BY COMING FORWARD
WE CHOOSE TO STAND UP FOR THE
SAFETY OF OUR COMMUNITY TO
LOWER THE RISK OF CALIFORNIA'S
CHILDREN BEING EXPOSED TO
SEXUAL PREDATORS IN OUR SCHOOL.
THIS IS NOT BEEN THE PATH OF
LEAST RESISTANCE AMONG THE MANY
UGLY TRUTH WE HAVE LEARNED ON
THIS JOURNEY IS THAT MANY WOULD
PREFER THIS ISSUE NEVER SEE THE
LIGHT OF DAY. THERE ARE FEW
THINGS WORSE THAN HARMING A
CHILD. ONE MIGHT BE PREVENTING
THAT SHOCKING SEEKING JUSTICE
FOR THAT HARM IGNORING THAT IT
EVER HAPPENED. FOUR YEARS AGO
OUR CHILD WAS REPEATEDLY AND
BRUTALLY RAPED BY A TEACHER AT
REDWOOD SCHOOL IN LOS ANGELES
NEARLY EVERY DAY FOR SEVERAL
MONTHS BOTH ON AND OFF CAMPUS.
RVTRADER REMOTELY CONVICTED AND
SERVING TIME. OUR CHILD HAS
BEEN PERMANENTLY CHANGED
DAMAGED AND SCARRED BY THE
THEORIES OF A FAULT. THE
ANGUISH PAIN AND MISERY COUPLED
WITH THE LOSS OF INNOCENCE HAVE
BEEN AND CONTINUE TO BE
CHALLENGING. HEIGHTENED BY THE
FACT THAT OUR CHARLES NEVER GOT
THE PROVERBIAL DAY IN COURT. A
JURY TRIAL WOULD BE IN ONE WAY
TO BRING ABOUT A FULL
INVESTIGATION OF THE CRIME AND
SCHOOLED POLICIES PROCEDURES
GUIDELINES GOVERNANCE AND
CULTURE WHICH MAY HAVE
CONTRIBUTED TO THE CRIME.
INSTEAD THE CIVIL JUSTICE
SYSTEM DID NOT A TRIAL THE JURY
TRIAL BECAUSE OF A MANDATORY
CONFIDENTIAL ARBITRATION CLAUSE
IN BRENTWOOD SCHOOL INVOLVEMENT
IN GREEN MINT. ARE TWELVE NOT
SIGNED AN AGREEMENT AND YET
WHAT HELP TO IT. MY HUSBAND AND
I FIND THAT AGREEMENT BELIEVING
THAT MOST ARBITRATION WOULD
COVER GRIEVANCES WE MIGHT HAVE
WITH THE SCHOOL REGARDING OUR
TRIAL EDUCATION. WE NEVER
ENVISIONED IT WOULD COVER A
FELONY CRIME AND WE CERTAINLY
NEVER ENVISIONED THAT WE WERE
SIGNING AWAY ARE TWELFTH RIGHT
TO CHOOSE THEIR OWN PATH TO
JUSTICE. NO PARENT DOES OR
SHOULD. THE CONTENT THE PARENT
TO FIND YOU THE PREMIUM IS THAT
ARBITRATION IS INTENDED TO
RESOLVE DISPUTES RELATED TO
ATTENDING A SCHOOL LIKE THIS
AGREEMENT ABOUT A GREAT ORANGE
ON. ARBITRATION CERTAINLY HAS
PLACE TO DOUBLE CHECK SYSTEM
BUT WAIT FIFTEEN SHOULD HAVE
THE RIGHT TO CHOOSE ARBITRATION
OR COURT. APPLYING THE
ARBITRATION QUALITY EDUCATORS
SEXUAL ABUSE OF A CHILD AT THE
POTENTIAL TO UNDERMINE ANY
CHANCE OF TRUE TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY. ARBITRATION
THAT IMPORTANT CONFIDENTIAL AND
REPORTEDLY LIMIT DISCOVERY IN
DISCLOSURE IS NOT ONLY BAD FOR
THE SEXUAL FALL VICTIM BUT ALSO
FOR SOCIETY. IT INSULATES THE
INVITATION FROM PUBLIC SCRUTINY
LEADING SCHOOLS COMPELLED TO
TRULY SELF REFLECTING MAKE THE
NECESSARY REFORMS TO PREVENT.
THE CRIMES THAT PROTECT YOU FOR
VICTIMS. ALL OF THOSE WHO WORK
A SCHOOL A SACRED AND WIDE
LEGAL DUTY TO PROTECT OUR TO.
WHEN CRIME TAKE PLACE IN THE
SCHOOL CONTEXT EVERYONE AGREES
THAT SOMETHING HAS GONE
HORRIBLY WRONG. BUT SHOULD
BILLS WON'T GO UNDER
INVESTIGATIVE ACOSTA WHEN THE
PARENTS AGREEING NOT TO SPEAK
OF THE SCHOOL OF A GRADE OR
PARKING. REGARDLESS OF THE
AMERICAN ARBITRATION UNPLUGGING
THE COURT SHOULD EXPECT TO GET
FULL CHILDREN BE AUTOMATICALLY
COVERED BEHIND THE CLOAK OF
CONFIDENTIAL ARBITRATION. I'D
LIKE MONTH IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE ARE BAFFLED AND
BOTHERED THAT UNDER CURRENT LAW
AN AGREEMENT SIGNED BY PARENTS
WITH THE CONDITION TO ATTEND A
SCHOOL IN CALIFORNIA PUT
OPERATE THE HIGH TECHS FIND
OTHER HIGH FELONIES BEHIND
CONFIDENTIAL ARBITRATION WE
IMPLORE YOU. TO CLOSE A
LOOPHOLE BY PASSING AB THREE
TWO SEVEN ONE INTO LAW. IN
SCHOOL FROM FORTY WEIGHT BUT-
ARBITER. BASED ON DECEPTIVE AND
WARM AGREEMENT. HAVING EIGHTY
THREE TWO SEVEN ONE OF THE
BOOKS WILL GO A LONG WAY TOWARD
HELPING OUR CHILD FEEL BY
KNOWING OTHER CHILDREN WILL NOT
BE IN A LONELY PAINFUL
PREDICAMENT AGAIN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR LISTENING. THANK
YOU. SO IS THERE ANYONE IN THE
ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY TWO
SEVENTY ONE. SEEING NONE- THERE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINES WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF AB THIRTY TWO SEVENTY ONE.
LADIES AND GENTLEMAN ON THE
PHONE LINE TO SHOW SUPPORT OF
AB THIRTY TWO SEVENTY ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN HERO AT
THIS TIME. AND I SAW NO ONE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MOVED TO
OPPOSITION I HAVE ONE
OPPOSITION WITNESS LISTED ROB
MUTRIE OUR ALLY. YES THANK YOU-
GOOD- GOOD MORNING JUST FIVE
MINUTES EVERYONE I'M ROBERT YOU
COULD HELP CHAMBER WHERE
BECAUSE THEY BE THIRTY TO
THIRTY ONE- BUT FIRST. AND
FOREMOST LET ME CLEAR OUR
POSITION I HAVE NOTHING TO DO
WITH- IS SEXUAL ASSAULT OR ANY
LACK OF CONCERN OVER WHAT WAS
JUST EXPRESSED THROUGH THE
TERRIBLE ACT WE KNOW WE CAN
DOWN SEXUAL WHILE THE MOST
CERTAINLY CONDEMN IT HOPE.
EVERYONE TO COMMIT SUCH ACT THE
PROP YOU TO HOLD AND THE LAW-
ALSO NOT OF ANY ISSUES REYES
RIGHT DECEPTION THANK SCHOOL TO
NEGOTIATE BILLION CONTRACT BUT
THEY'RE SEPARATE ISSUES- OUR
OUR ISSUE POLKA DOT THAT
CORRECTLYNOTED THE ISSUE OF
THE ARBITRATION AGREEMENT AND I
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR IS THAT
HAVING MULTIPLE LINK P.
DISCUSSIONS WITH US ON THIS
POINT- I WOULD AGREE WITH THAT.
AND BUT BECAUSE I THINK THATFOR THE THROWN OUT THAT AGREE
WITH THAT THE MAJORITY AT THE
K. POP CITED- AND STAFF POINT
TO THE ISSUE AT ALL ON A LOT OF
FOR YOU SIMPLY PUT OUR CONCERN
IS THAT- THIS BILL IS TOTALLY
PREEMPTED. SEVEN OKAY MATTER
HAD THAT- I THINK THE LINE THAT
THE THUMBS UP ARE CONCERNED-
THREE COURTS TWENTY ELEVEN KT
EIGHTY ANTI MOBILITY BECAUSE
THAT THE ON. THE COURT SAID.
QUOTE PERMIT. PERMIT THE
GREENEST ARE. TO BE VALIDATED
BY C<c.cyan>. GENERALLY APPLICABLE</c>
CONTRA DEFENSIVE BUT JUST FOR.
TO RESTAURANT BECAUSE- CLOSE
QUOTE. BUT NOT BY THE THAT THE
PLIGHT ONLY. ARBITER OR THE
DRIVE THEY MEETING THE FACT
THAT AGREE TO ARBITRATE IS THAT
EACH. IT READ THIS BILL ALL THE
FACT THERE THIS CREATE STABLE
CONTRACTED. UP BY. ONLY TO OUR-
FACULTY. EXIT THE GRIEVANCE
ARCH. THAT THE HEART OF OUR
CONCERNS THIS WILL DELETE IT
PREEMPTIVELY BELIEVE IT WILL BE
STRUCK DOWN COURT. AND VERIFY
THAT THE WAY PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
RESOURCE THEIR- WE THINK THIS
IS THAT THE GRANDFATHER BILL ON
THE POINT WITHOUT NOW THE- IT
IN THE RIGHT ROLE OF CASE LAW
WHICH SHOW THE- EIGHT. CULTURE
HERE THE WAY OTHER POINT I WILL
RAISE BRIEFLY THAT I THINK THE
AUTHOR AND- AND SUPPORTING
WITNESSES MENTION WITHIN NEXT
YEAR. THAT POINT I'M NOT AWARE
WE SPOKE TO THE AUTHOR AT
LENGTH OF ANY JURISPRUDENCE
FEDERALLY OR STATE WHICH-
CHANGES- THE CREATION OF A OF
AN ARBITRATION IF YOU'RE
PICKING BILL. BASED ON WHETHER
IT WAS INDEED. THAT JUST YOU
KNOW HOW TO SPEAK LIMIT.
OTHERWISE YOU HAVE A DEATH BY A
THOUSAND CUTS METHOD AROUND THE
FAM. SO WHAT WHAT TO TALK ABOUT
THAT CASE LAW AT ANY BUT WE DID
IT IS CLEARLY. PREEMPTED AND
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR ANYONE
IN THE HEARING ROOM WITH A TO
SPEAK OPPOSITION OF THE THIRTY
TWO SEVENTY ONE. SO NONE IS
THERE ANY ESE ON THE PHONE
LINES WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB. THIRTY TWO
SEVENTY ONE. ANYTHING GERAN
METAL MIND TO SHOW OPPOSITION
FOR AB THIRTY TWO SEVENTY ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THE TIME. AND I SHOW NO ONE
SHOWING OPPOSITION. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU OPERATOR I'M GONNA
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
THIS COMES OUT. I'D LIKE TO
MOVE THE BILL I WANT TO THANK
YOU THIS IS A- WONDERFUL BILL I
FEAR THAT THE OPPOSITION'S
CRACKED- HAVING. DONE ARE.
FORCED ARBITRATION BILLS THAT
HAVE BEEN A NOT EVEN GIVEN A
HEARING AND IN FEDERAL COURT
BASICALLY WITH WITH BEING- AN
INJUNCTION BUT I THINK IT'S A
START AND I THINK EVERY TIME WE
CAN PASS A BILL THAT MAKES
SENSE- WE CAN TACKLE. THE USE
OF FORCED ARBITRATION AND SOME
I'M HAPPY THAT YOU'RE DOING
THAT- AYE AYE IT AMAZES ME
YOU'RE DOING THIS BILL GIVEN
THAT YOU VOTED AGAINST MY
CHILDHOOD SEXUAL ASSAULT BILL-
LAST YEAR BUT YOU KNOW IT.
RIGHT I EMBRACE THE CHANGE BOTH
ON FORCED ARBITRATION AND ON
CHILDHOOD- SEXUAL MISCONDUCT IN
SCHOOL SO. I ABSOLUTELY- I'M
GRATEFUL THAT YOU'RE BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD AND I THANK
YOU FOR LOOKING OUT FOR
VICTIMS. THANK YOU THERE'S A
MOST IS THEIR SECOND. AND THE
SECOND THANK YOU. FOR THE
COMMENTS WAS TOGETHER. YEAH
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL IT AND THIS GOES TO- WE
HAD A SIMILAR- BILL A COUPLE
WEEKS AGO. DEALING WITH THIS
ISSUE- BUT WE YOU KNOW WE PUT A
LOT OF FOCUS ON. PRIVATE
ENTITIES SOME PRIVATE
INSTITUTIONS- YOU KNOW I CAN
THINK OF IS THAT THE CATHOLIC
CHURCH. ONE OF THEM AND THE
THINGS THAT THEY HAD DONE TO.
COVER UP TO MOVE PEOPLE AROUND-
TO AVOID DISCOVERY OF THESE
EGREGIOUS INJURIOUS SEXUAL
ASSAULTS- THAT WORKER ON PEOPLE
AND WHAT WE WILL WE HAVE NOT
PUT ENOUGH FOCUSING ATTENTION
ON. IS THE PUBLIC ENTITIES THAT
HAVE DONE VERY SIMILAR THINGS
AND THERE HAVE BEEN COUNTLESS.
THERE HAVE BEEN COUNTLESS
INCIDENTS OF TEACHERS WHO HAVE
COMMITTED THESE TYPES OF ACTS
AND THINGS HAVE NOT BEEN DONE
THINGS HAVE BEEN COVERED UP
THINGS HAVE BEEN- YOU KNOW NOT
DONE PROPERLY- TO THE INSURED
ESTES AN- AND A SAFE LEARNING
ENVIRONMENT FOR STUDENTS. AND
SO WE NEED TO HAVE WE CANNOT
ALLOW SOMETHING TO BE PUT UP
YOUR BECAUSE SOMETHING'S A
PUBLIC ENTITY- A WALL TO BE PUT
UP- TO JUSTICE AND SO I THINK
THIS IS VERY MUCH IN LINE WITH
THAT- SEVEN MEMBER WICKS IS
BILL- THAT MOVED OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE TWO WEEKS TWO WEEKS
AGO IS VERYMUCH AND- IN LINE
WITH THAT DEALING WITH UCLA-
SO. WE DO NEED TO REALLY START
PUTTING THE FOCUS ON THAT THERE
SHOULD BE IT SHOULD NOT MATTER
WHETHER YOU ARE A PUBLIC OR
PRIVATE AND IT IT YOU DID THESE
KINDS OF. IS IF YOU ALLOW
SOMETHING LIKE THIS TO HAPPEN
WHERE YOU KNOW WITH THIS YOUNG.
YOUNG MAN. THERE SHOULD NOT BE
A PET IMMENSE- TO JUSTICE AND I
AND I ALSO AGREE WITH THE WITH
YOUR- VIEW POINT- MISTER KILEY
THAT. THIS IS NOT A CONTRACTUAL
SITUATION YOU KNOW SCHOOL IS
COMPULSORY NOW THERE'S NOT
THERE'S NOT REALLY A THIS IS
NOT A- BE A WILLING VOLUNTARY
TRANSACTION BETWEEN THE
STUDENTS SCHOOL WE WANT ALL OF
OUR KIDS IN SCHOOL. AND SO CAN
WE REALLY ALLOW THESE AND
ROAMING AGREEMENTS- THAT THE
KID LIKELY NEVER EVEN SIGNED
HIS PARENTS SIGNED- BE THE
THING THAT KEEPS. JUSTICE FROM
BEING PERFORMED OF COURSE NOT-
AND SO THAT'S WHY I AM. I TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY AND
CONTINUE. ENSURING THAT THAT
JUSTICE HAPPENS IN THE PUBLIC
SECTOR- AS WELL AS IN THE
PRIVATE SECTOR THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ISRAEL. THANK YOU- I TO
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL. I THINK THIS BRINGS
US A STEP CLOSER TO REALLY
LOOKING OUT. FORCED ARBITRATION
WE HAVE PEOPLE ENTERING INTO
CONTRACTS- THAT SIGN AWAY
RIGHTS BECAUSE THAT'S THE ONLY
WAY THEY CAN GET INTO THIS
PRIVATE SCHOOL OR GET THIS JOB.
THIS IS THE FIRST STEP BUT I
THINK THAT WE NEED TO LOOK AT
IT AS MUCH GONZALEZ SAID THAT
THIS IS A THIS IS SOMETHING
BIGGER. I RECOGNIZE THAT HERE
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A MINOR. A
MINOR AS WE ALL KNOW CANNOT
ENTER INTO A CONTRACT. SO WE
HAVE PERRANCE. SIGNING WARY A
MINOR'S RIGHT. AND THEY SHOULD.
THEY SHOULD NOT BE ALLOWED IN
LOSS I DO APPRECIATE. THAT
YOU'RE DOING THIS. I ALSO HAD
THE BILL AS YOU MIGHT RECALL.
OF FOR YOU R. C. U. S. C. HAD
ALSO- THE THIRD THEIR DOCTOR
HAD. MOLESTED HAS SO MANY
FOURTEEN THOUSAND WOMEN THAT
CAME THROUGH THE DOORS WE HAVE
TO DO EVERYTHING THAT WE CAN TO
PROTECT. THOSE VULNERABLE
PEOPLE IN OUR COMMUNITY THE
FACT THAT WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
A MINOR IS MOST EGREGIOUS. SO I
AM HAPPY TO SUPPORT THIS AND I
DO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING IT
FORWARD. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTIONS COMMON. SIGNALS TO
KILEY MAY CLOSE I THINK THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION AND I ASPEN
OF IT. THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND THE MOTION
IS TO PASS CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE. STONE BY STONE AYE
GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER I'D SHOW
SO I. TO GONZALEZ CONSOLES I
HOLDEN. HOLDEN AYE KALRA. ALL
RIGHT I KILEY HI KILEY AYE
MAIENSCHEIN. OBERNOLTE
OBERNOLTE AYE RIVAS I'M SERIOUS
I. THAT HAS NINE VOTE HAS NINE
VOTES THAT BILL IS OUT. THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT WE WILL NOW DO.
TWO BILLS WILL WILL MOVE TO
ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTY ONE AND AFTER THAT
WE'LL DO ITEM NUMBER TEN A. B.
THIRTY THREE SIXTY SIX MR
GALLAGHER. YEAH OKAY. I THINK
YOU CAN DO IT FROM YOUR CHANNEL.
THANK YOU. YEAH. YES MISTER
CHAIRMAN- GO ARE YOU PROCEEDING
ON THE MISTER MAIN CHAINS BILL
YES YOU DID OKAY- LIKE TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH AB TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTY ONE OF THE BILL GO
AHEAD PROCEED THANK YOU MEMBERS
EXISTING LAW CALIFORNIA LAW
PROVIDES CONSUMERS A THREE DAY
RIGHT TO CANCEL CERTAIN
CONTRACTS AFTER SIGNING AND
THESE ARE CONTRACTS RECOGNIZES
INVOLVING HIGH PRESSURE SALES
TACTICS SUCH AS HOME
SOLICITATION CONTRACTORS
SEMINAR SALES CONTRACTS AND
PASTE FINANCING AGREEMENTS HIGH
PRESSURE SALES TACTICS CAN
MISLEAD CONSUMERS WHO MAY NOT
FULLY COMPREHEND THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN FOR WILL PRESENT THE
VERBAL PRESENTATION AN ACTUAL
TERMS OF THE WRITTEN CONTRACT.
SENIOR CITIZENS ARE OFTEN THE
VICTIMS OF THESE HIGH PRESSURE
SALES TACTICS PUTTING THEIR
RETIREMENT SAVINGS AND ASSETS
AT RISK WE HAVE OF MR
MAIENSCHEIN. I AM PRESENTING AB
TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY ONE WHICH
PROVIDED DIGITAL PROTECTION TO
SENIORS DEVICE THAT'S TRULY EXT
TENDING THE RIGHT T CANCEL
FROM THREE BUSINESS DAYS TO
FIVE BUSINESS DAYS. FOR THESE
TYPES OF CONTRACTS THERE ARE
TWO WITNESSES SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT COLLEEN WHO'S GOT. THE
DEPUTY DA FROM SAN DIEGO COUNTY%
AND LARRY MORSE THE LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION
AND WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK ON BEHALF OF MR BEACH I'D-
FOR YOUR ITEMS. ALL RIGHT- WILL
PROCEED WITH WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. TO WE HAVE A LOT OF
SAN DIEGANS WITH US TODAY.
CIGARETTE NOON VIDEO THE MOUSE
TO WORK THANK YOU. ATTORNEY
KHALID SHOW OF THE CONSUMER
PROTECTION UNIT OF THE SAN
DIEGO COUNTY THIS IS TURNING
OFFICE REPRESENTING. ERNIE
SUMMER STAFF IN SAN DIEGO
DISTRICT ATTORNEY IS CO
SPONSORING AB TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTY ONE ALONG WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION. AB TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTY ONE IS A
STRAIGHTFORWARD PROPOSAL TO
EXTEND THE RIGHT TO CANCEL FOR
INDIVIDUALS SIXTY FIVE YEARS
OLD AND OVER FROM THREE
BUSINESS DAYS TO FIVE BUSINESS
DAYS. THE NATIONAL TWO DAYS ARE
DESIGNED TO PROACTIVELY PROTECT
SENIOR FROM ENTERING INTO
CONTRACTS WHICHUPON REFLECTION
DO NOT SUIT THEIR NEEDS- WHICH
HAVE BEEN MISREPRESENTED OR
MISUNDERSTOOD. THE FIVE
CATEGORIES OF CONTRACT
INCUMBENTS BY THESE AMENDMENTS
ARE COLD SO WHAT CONTRACT. HOME
IMPROVEMENT CONTRACTOR PROPERTY
AFFECT CLEAN ENERGY OR PACE
ASSESSMENT CONTRACT. THERE IS A
REPAIR CONTRACTS AND SEMINARS
FAILED CONTRACT. AS NOTED IN
THE PREAMBLE. CONTRACT ARE
OFTEN ENTERED INTO AFTER HIGH
PRESSURE SALES TACTICS AND
OFTEN RESULT IN LARGE FINANCIAL
OBLIGATIONS. ORACLE ENTERING
INTO THESE CATEGORIES THE
CONTRACT CAN BE AVOIDED OR
MITIGATED THE SAFEGUARDS
ALLOWING ADDITIONAL TIME TO
CONSIDER THE BENEFIT OF THE
CONTEMPLATED PURCHASE. COMPARE
THE WRITTEN CONTRACT TERMS TO
THE VERBAL PROMISES. AND
CONSULT WITH FAMILY MEMBERS OR
OTHER TRUSTED ADVISER BEFORE
UNDERTAKING THE FINANCIAL
OBLIGATIONS. HOME IMPROVEMENT
AND PACE ASSESSMENT CONTRACT IN
PARTICULAR INVOLVED THE LARGEST
FINANCIAL ASSET MANY SENIOR
CITIZENS HAVE THEIR HOME WHAT
CAN BE PLACED AT RISK OR EVEN
LAW TO FORECLOSURE AS A RESULT
THE CONTRACT. WHICH ARE
MISREPRESENTED OR MISS
UNDERSTOOD. LAST YEAR OUR
OFFICE AS A MEMBER OF A STATE
WIDE PATH TOWARDS. ELEVATE
AMERICA ONE OF CALIFORNIA'S
LARGEST PASTED MINISTRY- UNFIR
BUSINESS PRACTICES AND FALSE
ADVERTISING. AS PART OF THE
SETTLEMENT OF THAT CIVIL LAW
ENFORCEMENT ACTION RENOVATE
AMERICA AGREED TO CERTAIN
JUMPED INFORMATION BUT WE
DESIGNED TO PROTECT SENIOR
INCLUDED EXTENDED RIGHT TO
CANCEL FOR A NUMBER OF ENERGY
EFFICIENT HOME IMPROVEMENT
PROJECTS THE THREE TO FIVE
BUSINESS DAYS. AB TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTY ONE CODIFIED WHAT HAD
BEEN NEGOTIATED IN THAT
AGREEMENT TO PROTECT SENIORS
WHO AGGRESSIVE SALES TACTICS.
AND HARMONIZES THE FIVE DAY
EXTENSION THIRTEEN YEARS ACROSS
THE OTHER CATEGORIES. WE HAVE
THE SAME UNDERLYING PRESSURES.
WE ALSO ANTICIPATE THAT SENIORS
WILL ENTER INTO MORE OF THE
TYPE OF CONTRACT COVERED BY
THESE AMENDMENTS IN THE COMING
MONTHS AND YEARS. AS A RESULT
OF THE COLD NINETEEN CRISIS. AS
A SCIENTIST CLARIFYING EACH DAY.
ARE MORE AT RISK THE NEGATIVE
EFFECTS OF CONTRACTING KOBE
NINETEEN. AS A RESULT WHETHER
FROM GOVERNMENT HELP DIRECTED
OR TO PERSONAL CHOICE WE
ANTICIPATE SENIOR TO BE
ENTERING INTO THE SORT OF
CONTRACT COVERED. THEY MAY WISH
TO UPGRADE OR RENOVATE THEIR
HOME THEY MAY ALSO BE APPROACH
TO HOLD SOLICITATION OR DURING
SEMINAR FAILED ABOUT VARIOUS
SERVICES THAT IS DESIGNED TO
PERHAPS CLEAN SANITIZED AND
PROTECT THEMSELVES AND THEIR
LIVING SPACE. FROM THE VIRUS.
WE HAVE ALL THE INFORMATION
ABOUT KOBE NINETEEN AND THE
NEED TO REVIEW CREDIBLE
INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT SERVICE
IS THE PRODUCT THEY'RE
EFFICACIOUS. AND WHICH PROVIDER
THE COMPANIES ARE REPUTABLE
WILL REQUIRE ADDITIONAL TIME TO
REVIEW WOULD DISCUSS. WITH
TRUSTED BY THE FAMILY MEMBERS.
I WILL REMAIN ON THE LINE IF
YOU HAVE ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS
AND RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU
DEBBIE DISTRICT ATTORNEY HESKEY
HAVE MISTER MOORE ST I WILL
REMIND YOU WE HAVE A SUPPORT
SUPPORT ON THIS- SO. PROCEED.
OKAY DO WE HAVE MISTER MORRIS
THEIR- I DO NOT SENATOR MARK ON
THE PHONE LINE. ALL RIGHT DO
ANYBODY ANY OTHER. THIS IS IN
SUPPORT IN THE AUDIENCE. SEEN
NONE- WILL- ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINES TWENTY TWO. GIVE SUPPORT.
TO AB TWENTY FOUR SEVEN YOU.
LADIES AND GENTLEMAN ON THE
PHONE LINE TO SHOW SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. LOCAL TO LINE NUMBER
SIXTY THREE LINES SIXTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON PERSONAL GET OFF ON
BEHALF OF LOS ANGELES CITY
ATTORNEY MIKE HERE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AT THE
BOTTOM LINE NUMBER FORTY NINE
ONE FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO CATALINA SAYS
ACCORDING HI THERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME
CONSUMER COALITION AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU. BOTTOM LINE NUMBER
SIXTY FIVE ONE SIXTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI LARRY MORSE-
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION
WE'RE PROUD TO BE A CO SPONSOR
OF THE SUPPORT CONSUMER
LEGISLATION WE ARE JULY BOAT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
MARS. NEXT PHOTO MY NUMBER
SIXTY SIX IN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
BACK IN MARKET ON BEHALF OF THE
CENTER FOR PUBLIC INTEREST LAW
IN SUPPORT. AND LOCAL TO MY
NUMBER THIRTY TO ONE THIRTY TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ANNA BACK ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS IN
SUPPORT. AND AS A REMINDER TO
SHOW SUPPORT TO AB TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTY ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. I SURE
NO ONE ELSE PART. OKAY ANY
OPPOSITION. I DON'T HAVE ANY
WITNESSES ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. SCENE
NINE- ANY OPPOSITION. IN THE
AUDIENCE SCENE NINE ANY
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE LINES.
TO SHOW OPPOSITION ON THE OVER
THE PHONE LINE FOR BILL AB
TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY ONE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
THANK CHAU NO ONE SHOWING
OPPOSITION. OKAY WITHOUT BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE WAS
MISTER MAIN SHINES NON
CONTROVERSIAL BILL. WHAT'S YOUR
PLEASURE. AT THE GARY HEARD OF
FOR THE- MOTION AND THE SECOND
IS THAT CORRECT THE- OKAY IS
THERE A MOTION. MOVED BY MISS
REYES SECOND ABOUT MR HOLDEN.
THAT ROLL ROLL CALL THE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. AND FOR CLEARLY
THE MOTION IS TO PASS. STONE
AYE STONE AYE GALLAGHER HI
FELDER I JOE SO I CHIU.
GONZALEZ CONSOLES I HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE KALRA KALRA AYE
KILEY KILEY AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE I REYES
REZAI. THE BILL HAS NINE VOTES
NUMBER SEVEN BILLS OUT. AND
MISTER CHAIRMAN WOULD YOU LIKE
TO PROCEED WITH YOUR NEXT BILL
THANK YOU AB THIRTY THREE SIXTY
SIX DEALS WITH JUDICIAL
EMERGENCIES IN CALIFORNIA UNDER
CURRENT LAW THE CHIEF JUSTICE
MAY ISSUE ORDERS TO MODIFY
COURT RULES AND PROCEDURES
DURING A DECLARED EMERGENCY.
BUT UNDER GOVERNMENT CODE
SECTION SIXTY EIGHT ONE ONE
FIVE IT ONLY ALLOWS CHIEF
JUSTICE TO ISSUE ORDERS
AFFECTING A SINGLE COUNTY UPON
THE REQUEST OF THE PRESIDING
JUDGE OF THE SUPERIOR COURT FOR
THAT COUNTY AND AS WE SAW WITH
THE STATE WIDE EPIDEMIC OR-
THAT WITH THIS STATEWIDE
EPIDEMIC WERE WITH A DISASTER
THAT COVERS MULTIPLE COUNTIES
THAT LAW IS ENOUGH REALLY
WORKABLE AND IN FACT FOR THEIR
CURRENT PANDEMIC. THE GOVERNOR
HAD TO ISSUE AN EXECUTIVE ORDER
IN ORDER TO GIVE THESE.
ABILITIES TO THE CHIEF JUSTIC
THIS BILL MERELY PROVIDES FOR A
STATEWIDE WHERE YOU MULTI
COUNTY ABILITY FOR THE CHIEF
JUSTICE. TO BE ABLE TO DO.
MODIFY PROCEDURES IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT JUSTICE HAPPENS
THROUGHOUT ALL OF OUR COURTS
THIS IS A SIMPLE BUT PRETTY
IMPORTANT MEASURE. AND YOU'LL
NOTICE THIS THIS BILL WITH HAD
WAS HAS BEEN HEAVILY AMENDED SO
THE BECAUSE WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING WITH BOTH SIDES AND IN
SUPPORT WE HAVE WITNESSES FROM
BOTH THE CONSUMER TOURNEY'S AND
THE CALIFORNIA DEFENSE COUNSEL.
AND BOTH OF THEM BEING ON THIS
BILL SHOWS THE AMOUNT OF
AMENDMENTS WE'VE TAKEN TRYING
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE GIVING
APPROPRIATE LEVELS. OF
AUTHORITY TO THE CHIEF JUSTICE
IN SITUATIONS LIKE THESE SO
THAT JUSTICE CAN HAPPEN AND
WITH THAT REYES RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR I'VE LIVED. MOVE THEM
AS REYES SECONDED BY MISS
GONZALEZ- ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT I HAVE TO ON FILE HERE
MIKE HELLO. AND NANCY DRABBLE.
YES MISTER CHAIR THIS IS NANCY
TRAVEL WITH CONSUMER ATTORNEYS
OF CALIFORNIA WE ARE VERY HAPPY
TO SUPPORT THIS BILL IT IS
ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL AS MR
STONE MENTIONED WE THOUGHT HOW.
UNFORTUNATELY DYSFUNCTIONAL THE
CURRENT STATUTE IS BECAUSE IT
REALLY DID NOT ANTICIPATE A
PANDEMIC- AND FOR THE THOSE OF
OUR MEMBERS AND ALSO FOR
DEFENSE COUNSEL DEALING WITH
CIVIL CASES WE SAW THAT THE
CHIEF JUSTICE DID NOT HAVE.
ADEQUATE AUTHORITY AND WOULD
THAT FORCE TO WAIT FOR VARIOUS
REQUEST AN INDIVIDUAL COURT IN
FACT I BELIEVE SHE RESPONDED.
TO OVER A HUNDRED REQUIRED HIM
INDIVIDUAL COURT AND THEN- SHE
HAD TO WAIT FOR AN EXECUTIVE
ORDER AUTHORITY FROM THE
GOVERNOR- THAT MEANT THAT THE
COURT LOST SOME TIME. THE FIRST
THE CASES AND IS A RESULT OF
THIS OF CLEAR AUTHORITY FOR A
PANDEMIC SOME OF THE BACKLOG-
THAT WE ARE NOW FACING FOR
ACCESS TO JOB TO HAVE INCREASED
SO GOING FORWARD WE THINK IT IS
ESSENTIAL THAT THE CHIEF
JUSTICE HAVE. STATEWIDE
AUTHORITY TO DEAL WITH THE
STATEWIDE EMERGENCY. THANK YOU.
AND MISTER KERIK MIKE BELOW
TWENTY OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEFENSE COUNSEL. FOLLOWING UP
ON MS GRAVELS COMMENTS THIS WAS
A LESSON FROM THE PANDEMIC AND
WE'RE LEARNING LOTS OF LESSONS-
THIS IS NOT INTERROGATION OF A
PRESIDING JUDGES ABILITY TO
TAILOR. PROCEDURES BASED ON
THE- ISSUES FACING LOCAL COURTS
BUT RATHER A RECOGNITION THAT
WE HAVE A STATE COURT SYSTEM
THAT OUR MEMBERS PRACTICE IN
MULTIPLE JURISDICTIONS AND IT'S
CRITICAL TO KNOW WHAT THE
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS RULES
WILL BE IN EFFECT- WHAT-
HEARING DEADLINE RULES WILL BE
IN EFFECT PEOPLE PRACTICE MULTI
JURISDICTIONAL A AND- THE MORE
UNIFORMITY WE CAN HAVE AROUND
THE STATE- SUBJECT TO LOCAL
CONDITIONS THE BETTER OFF WE
ARE. AND SO WE'RE PROUD TO
JOIN- THE CONSUMER ATTORNEYS IN
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE ON THE
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU- ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT IN THE
AUDIENCE TODAY. ANY FURTHER
WITNESSES SUPPORT ON THE PHONE
LINES. ID ONE ZERO IF YOU'RE IN
SUPPORT. AND THERE'S NO ONE IN
SUPPORT. OKAY ANY OPPOSITION
WITNESSES. CNN WE HAVE ANY A
BUDDY OF MINE TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION IN THE AUDIENCE. AND
ANY OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE
LINES. IF YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THE
TIME. WE DO HAVE ONE GIVING UP.
THERE'S AT THE MOMENT. IN
NINETEEN SIXTY FOUR YOUR LIGHT
AND BUT- GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS OUT OF
REGULAR WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE. ONE OF THE
EXPRESS OUR GRATITUDE TO THE
COMMITTEE CONSULTANT AND STAFF
WORKING ON THE AMENDMENTS WE
WERE INITIALLY OPPOSED TO THE-
INTRODUCED LANGUAGE AND WITH
THE AMENDMENT THAT THE
COMMITTEE PLANS TO TAKE. THE
CHAMBER WILL BE GOING TO A NO
POSITION AND THERE'LL BE A
NUMBER OF- ENTITY THAT SIGNED
ON TO OUR OPPOSITION COALITION
WILL ALSO BE CHANGING TO A
NEUTRAL OR NO POSITION. AND WE
WILL ONCE REFLECTED IN PRINT
THE MINUTE CHANGE OF POSITION
REFLECTING THAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. IF THERE ANY OTHER THAN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. THERE'S
NO ONE ELSE IN THE QUEUE. OKAY
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
WE ALREADY HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND- ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. SCENE NINE WILL CALL
YEAH I DID HAVE ONE QUESTION
HAVE WE HEARD FROM THE
PRESIDING JUDGES AT ALL IS
THERE ANY DISCUSSION WE'VE
GOTTEN BACK FROM THE MISTER
TURNER WE'VE NOT HAD ANY ISSUES
WITH. FOR THE PRESIDING JUDGES.
OKAY MEDICAL CLOUT CALL THE
ROLL OF A CLOSE. YES GET AN
EMOTIONAL IF YOU PASS AS
AMENDED BECAUSE THIS BILL HAS
BEEN. AMENDED QUITE A BIT OVER
THE COURSE OF IT AND THE
ANALYSIS REFLECTS THE AMENDED
BILL SO I JUST WANT TO MAKE IT.
CLEAR ON THE RECORD THEM
ACCEPTING THOSE AMENDMENTS AND
I ASKED WE WRITE ABOUT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I'M SORRY- I
DON'T BELIEVE I HAVE A MOTION
AND SECOND. THE MOTION- MUST
READ AND SECONDED BY MISTER
HOLDEN. A STONE FIVE STONE AYE
GALLAGHER AYE FELDER I SHOW SO
I CHU CHU AYE GONZALEZ AND
THOSE AYE HOLDEN. HOLDEN AYE
KALRA. KALRA BY. KILEY NON.
KELLY NOT VOTING MAIENSCHEIN
OBERNOLTE. OBERNOLTE NOT VOTING
REYES. HI RES I. SHE'S THAT HAS
EIGHT BUT- WHAT ABLE TO DOUBLE
THE BILLS OUT. YEP THANK YOU.
OKAY LET'S NOW ROLL BACK
THROUGH ALL OF THE ITEMS WE
HAVE SEVERAL BILLS ARE CALL
MOST OF THE BILLS HAVE PASSED
OUT OF THE COMMITTEE SO LET'S
RUN THROUGH FROM THE TOP ITEM
NUMBER ONE IS AB TWENTY FOUR
SIXTY THREE WHICH IS ON CALL IN
THE LIFT THE CALL. COMING UP TO
MEMBERS PLEASE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NOT VOTING. TO AYE
HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE KILEY. KILEY
AYE OBERNOLTE NOT VOTING. THE
BILL HAS EIGHT FOLKS SO AB
TWENTY FOUR SIXTY THREE IS OUT
THANK YOU. ITEM NUMBER TWO IS
AB TWENTY THREE THIRTY EIGHT BY
WHATEVER IT IS OUT OF THE
COMMITTEE BUT WOULD YOU CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NOT VOTING. CHU CHU I.
HOLDEN HOLDEN I. AND
MAIENSCHEIN. GALLAGHER I. THAT
HAS TEN VOTES OKAY THAT WAS
ALREADY OUT SO ITEM NUMBER
THREE IS AB TWENTY FOUR FORTY
TWO BY MR CHALLENGES ON CALL.
MIDDLE IF THE CALL. TWO FIVE TO
BUY GONZALEZ AND SALAS I HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I. AND MAIENSCHEIN. AND
THAT HAS SEVEN VOTES THANK YOU
THE BILL IS OUT. I REMEMBER FOR
AB TWENTY FOUR FORTY FIVE I
MISS REYES IS ALREADY OUT BUT
LOW ADD ONS A CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. TWO FIVE CHU I HOLDEN
HOLDEN HI. AND MAIENSCHEIN.
THANK YOU ITEM NUMBER FIVE IS
AB TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY ONE BY
MR MAIENSCHEIN THE BILL IS
ALREADY OUT I'M NOT SURE WE
HAVE EVERYBODY LISTED BUT IF
YOU CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS TWO
FIVE TWO I. OKAY THAT'S IT.
ITEM NUMBER SIX AB THIRTY
TWENTY BY MR GLORIA IS ON CALL
I'M GOING TO LIFT THE CALL. TWO
HI CHIU AYE HOLDEN. HOLDEN I.
IT HAS SEVEN. GREAT THE BILL IS
OUT THANK YOU I REMEMBER SEVEN
AB THIRTY ONE THIRTY THREE BY
MS AGUIAR-CURRY IS OUT BUT CALL
THE UP TO MEMBERS THAT ARE TOO
HIGH. TWO I. HOLDEN HOLDEN I.
ORANGE LINE THANK YOU NUMBER
EIGHT IS AB THIRTY TO FIFTY
FOUR BY MS LOW MOAN IT IS
ALREADY OUT OF THE COMMITTEE
BUT IF MEMBERS WISH THAT ON
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS TO HI
CHU I. HOLDEN HOLDEN I
MAIENSCHEIN. OKAY AN ITEM
NUMBER NINE AB THIRTY TWO
SEVENTY ONE BY MR KILEY IS OUT
OF THE COMMITTEE BUT IF YOU YOU
COULD CALL THE AS A MEMBER STAT
ON TWO FIVE. TWO I. MAIENSCHEIN
OKAY AND DO WE HAVE EVERYBODY
ON ITEM NUMBER TEN A. B. THIRTY
THREE SIXTY SIX YES WE DO ALL
RIGHT THAT'S IT THANK YOU ALL
VERY MUCH WE ARE A JERK.